[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello lol oh yeah you can hear me great
[Music]
[Music]
vertical video
[Music]
Oh
ready
[Music]
[Music]
I'm plugging myself into this thing so I
can so I can add my own little subtitle
here
alright that should pop up Quincey
Larson yeah I add hey everybody watching
on stream welcome we are at the 2018 Top
Contributor party for free coke am super
excited to be here with everybody and
I'm gonna be interviewing a lot of these
top contributors to the free coke camp
code base and community and all of our
infrastructure so be sure to tell your
friends that we're live-streaming here
you're just kickin it having a relaxing
Saturday night or Sunday morning
depending on what part of the world
you're in and I am very eager to start
talking all these people I think before
I do any of that I'm going to address
the crowd and welcome everybody so we'll
do that in just a minute if you want in
the meantime you can just kind of swoop
around through the audience
we can check out the space first we're
gonna be kind of moving around the whole
thing all right it's a little okay it's
a little quieter over here but basically
this is the entryway we're at rough
draft in Brooklyn NYC tonight we're
having a good time
invite only for the Top Contributor
party we've got lots of beverages and
lots of food and lots of exciting people
who I'm excited to talk to in a moment
Wow that worked I didn't actually have
to say Sh it just worked so um first of
all everybody say hi to our audience on
stream there are people all around the
world who are watching right now and we
are going to probably have a lot more
people join us throughout the night and
just check in and see because we've
talked a lot about the 2018 Top
Contributor party I spent so much time
laboring over whom to select and I am
very confident that I made the right
decisions looking around the room like
pretty this is pretty much a who's who
of people who have made the freako camp
community what it is today and what is
the freako camp community all right
thank you Tony
so freako camp is a global community of
developers who are helping people in
their communities learn to code we have
a ton of free open-source learning
materials ton of Creative Commons
learning material we have a ton of
videos on YouTube we have a ton of
articles on medium we have a ton of
podcast episodes and we have an
incredible curriculum that the entire
community has come together and sculpted
over the past three and a half years and
everything is completely free and open
source free code camp itself is now a
501 C 3 non-profit which means that
we're tax exempt and any donations to
freako camp are tax deductible if you
happen to have like an employee matching
thing at your office or something keep
that in mind
or if you just happen to have like a
killer a year and you don't want your
tax liabilities to be too big so but
we're doing a lot of exciting things
with the donations from our community
we're powering servers that right now if
I were to look there probably be four or
five hundred people using the core
learning platform even Saturday night we
have millions of people using free code
camp every month all around the world we
have a ton of people
in India we have a ton of people in
Nigeria Bangladesh China has more than a
hundred thousand active campers and then
here in the u.s. of course Europe Latin
America Central America all over the
world Africa even Australia where I was
last month and Australians are the most
chilled people I have to say so we have
a lot of people from all around the
world here tonight and I am going to try
to talk to every single one of you live
on stream if you're cool with it and
just talk a little bit about how you got
involved in free code camp what you're
interested in doing in the coming year
what your own personal goals are for
your career oh and of course why you
became part of this community what what
encouraged you to take your scarce free
time and turn around and invest it into
an open-source project aimed at helping
increase technology literacy so I'm very
excited to talk with all you just to
give you a quick recap on how free code
camp is doing we have recently launched
the new curriculum about two months ago
and it's been very popular so far there
are a lot of ways we can continue to
improve it it's never going to be
finished it's always going to be a work
in progress
we have tons of study groups around the
world many of whom the leadership of
which is here today and we're going to
talk about the future of those study
groups in ways that we can further
expand them and make it easier for
people to start study groups and
participate in study groups and make it
easier for people to find study groups
and we're we're thinking about ways we
can take the hundreds of people that are
using free kokum at any given moment and
raise awareness if there's a study group
in their City right there on free cokie
org just in time like hey a study group
is starting in six hours
would you like to RSVP and also take the
study groups and make them more granular
so you don't have to go you don't have
to commute 30 minutes
to get to a study group after work
there's a neighborhood study group and
then there's like a city level study
group that meets once a week or once a
month so we'll have a much more granular
spread out distributed community where
people are learning to code in smaller
groups and coming together for bigger
events we're working on hackathon tools
to make it easier for us to have big
online hackathons where everybody can
join in and participate wherever they
are in the world our values are of
course being completely free being
convenient for busy people who have kids
who have full-time jobs we're going to
school full-time who have elderly
parents they're taking care of all kinds
of people who are all kinds of busy and
we want to be a resource that
acknowledges twenty eighteen people are
busier than ever there's no sign of
people being less busy in the near
future we want to make it so it's
convenient for all of you to sit down
and get in 30 minutes of coding today an
hour of coding a day maybe just do a
long weekend where you build up an app
over the course of several hours we want
to be here for you all so you can
continue to expand your skills
throughout your in your career as you
progress and as you transition from
field to field and as you get more and
more technical over time so thank you
again everyone for joining me I think at
this point if it's cool I'd like to pass
the microphone around and have everyone
briefly introduce themselves to
everybody else and I think the way we
can do this is your name where you're
from and what your near-term goals are
if you have a goal like you want to take
your study group and have it be from
instead of once a month have it be once
a week if your goal is to open more pull
requests against the free code camp
guide or if you want to contribute to
Firefox or some other major open-source
projects if you want to get more
freelance clients whatever your goal is
I think this would be a great
opportunity
for you to share it with the world and
kind of commit no pressure and if you
don't have a goal if your goal is just
to continue doing more of this what
you're doing fantastic you can just say
so
and if you don't want to be on stream
just let me know just kind of like and
walk over toward a corner where you'll
be on the stream alright so I think we
can just start over here there's Billy
Lee I'm Billy I'm from Sacramento
California and minor term goal is just
to improve on my skill set
I'm just doing some more at least event
you know react stuff so hey everybody
I'm Nicole our Shambo I'm from Boston
I am the organizer of the Metro West
Massachusetts free code camp meetup and
that's a tough one Quincy I think my
short and near term goals are not only
grow up my my meetup group but also to
help all of freako camp students in some
really unique ways hello i'm salic I'm
from Lima Peru and my well I actually
organize meetups in over there in South
America and my short and medium-term
goals are organizing more meetups
making them weekly on a weekly basis and
making different no different kind of
different kind of meters like one meetup
is just going doing the free cotton
curriculum the next meetup may be a
hackathon based on the stock that were
you
you
okay yeah so I'm sure I'm a developer
for freako camp and my short term goal
is to help freako camp expand its reach
around the world hi I'm mark I run a
local group
you
in the middle so once again I'm mark
from Oslo Norway and I run local a local
group there we've wonderful people there
and we are preparing now for our second
hackathon because we just finished our
first one so we are getting excited
about it thanks so I'm Bill from Ottawa
Canada and yeah Canada and the short
term goal is just continue mentoring and
helping as many devs as I can through
articles on the free code camp blog and
through my newsletter etc and probably
soon ish build build an online course to
help people even more so that's the plan
hello I'm George from Tokyo Japan
I am organizer with a TGIF recall camp
you can find us meetup site and we have
every Friday we have been meeting in
Tokyo thank you
I am Tim from Colombo Sri Lanka
currently I'm working with a skills
skill registration platform using
blockchain so my short term goal I'm
wondering whether we could register
skills and the certificates making free
code camp in this particular platform so
that that's what I am working on right
now
hi I'm Michael Sam Cohen from New York
and I run free coke in meetup group here
on two days a week and as far as
short-term goals go it's really it's
really hard to say because there's many
conflicting ones and they keep
overlapping with each other but one of
the ones that popped into my head right
now is I would like to do more targeted
talks on different specific things like
filling gaps in knowledge filling gaps
in knowledge that people might have for
example how do you how do you start
using it because you need to start using
it if you haven't been doing it already
how do you tie react and redux together
how do you transition from just being a
front-end to front-end and back-end you
know things like this that I feel like
I'm missing in some people also I would
like to get involved with the
development of the curriculum one but
you know whenever ya medium term go yeah
I'm Victoria Carey Olek and I'm here in
New York City as well groups that we
have every week for three years things
to mike short-term goal in addition to
what Mike said perhaps we'd like to get
a hackathon going similar to what also
has done they have a great medium
article and I'm planning on going
through that and coming up with
something another New York person I'm
Megan I work with the New York City
group I'm an admin for the Facebook
group and last year I was running
Saturday meetups but those weren't doing
so hot so now it's just sort of like
pop-up meetups and as far as my goals
for free code camp it'd be the same
thing as Mike and Victoria I think we
need more sort of specialized meetups
rather than just generalized study
groups so that we can talk about
specific topics or get together and all
just commit to hacking for a few hours
at a time rather than just two hours on
a weeknight so yeah
hello campers my name is Jennifer bland
I'm from Atlanta Georgia one thing that
I want to contribute on is I was
recently selected into the nodejs
mentorship program they're doing this
now they're trying to get more people to
contribute to open source code
especially with nodejs and they started
it in a beta phase where they only
accepted four people out of 800 and I
was one of the four I'm writing articles
about it you will be seeing on the
publication I'm also creating videos
about my experience and that so that I
can share that with other campers so
that they can learn as they're learning
how to code how they can go back and
contribute to open source and show them
how easy it is to be able to do that so
thank you hi everybody my name is Abby
and I'm also on the free code camp team
so happy to be here with everybody and
my near-term goal is to just enjoy the
remaining 48 hours with my team it's not
often we get to get together so really
really great to have a couple more days
with them so I'm just stoked on
everything here I'm Ariel I'm Ariel
Leslie on the forums I moderate there
and try and answer questions I'm in
Boulder Colorado and my goal is more
personal and not about y'all I start in
two weeks my master's in computer
science hi my name is Bo Carnes I'm from
Grand Rapids Michigan and I'm excited
I'm able to work full-time with freako
camp now and also one of my goals I'm
currently making scrim videos to go with
all the challenges on the curriculum and
so my goal is to finish that up and get
get videos to go along with all the
challenges so to help even more people
get through and learn learn the
curriculum and also my second goal is
that I'm I'm my goal is to convert a
school bus into an RV
hi I'm Tony Moscone Coates from San
Diego via Hawaii and I think my I'm also
an owl ricci intern I have to say this
because they've I mean here and I'm
proud to be a member of the medium team
and yeah we are great the editors on
that on that medium is awesome because
we aren't and so I think my current goal
is to finish my outreach program and
continue learning front end libraries
and just keep learning and sharing as
much as I can
hello I am Ethan I am a student at
Wentworth Institute of Technology up in
Boston
currently interning at Microsoft and my
short term goal is definitely to finish
working on the Python curriculum for
free code camp and getting that up and
running so that everyone can start
learning Python on free code camp hi
hello I'm Johnny Bissell from Leeds in
England what can I say
I'm really glad to be here to meet
everyone one of the reasons I'm here is
to network with other people which is
one of Quincy's recommendations saying
when you actually meet and talk to
people in real life
it stops you being stuck behind a
computer behind the desk I've been
working on free code camp for about
three years now nearly completed it so
my short term goal is to complete the
course
and get all the certificates I also
involved in the local group in my city
we have meet a coffee and code session
every fortnight and that's going quite
well
else I'll think of something like and
I'll pass it on for now thank you hi my
name is Joe Hill I'm from Norfolk
Virginia by way of Canada and Ireland
yay I think my I have two goals once
professional and I free code camp led me
from completing a free front-end
certification to going right into being
a sequel and T sequel developer
professionally and so now I'm trying to
wrap my head around this whole world of
data and so now I'm trying to learn
Python and more of sequel and more
Microsoft stack so that's more
professional what I'm trying to do in
last year by way of the meetup I started
to meet up I think right when Norfolk
free code can't meet up right when
Quincy put out a call for local groups
to start up so it's been about four
years now I think I think that's when I
started free code camp itself so what
we've been doing last year has been
we've been kind of sporadic as far as
having a meet-up every month and there
would be on different topics like one
would be like on iOS development and
another one would be you know react or
something like that so we'd be getting
new groups every time but it doesn't
seem like anybody was getting any
traction so been trying to do one every
two weeks virtually just on Google
Hangouts and just do it working through
algorithms working through projects
doing show and tells and I think that's
been a big help because everybody can
work through the curriculum together so
that's what we're gonna keep trying to
do
hi I'm going Faraday Indianapolis
Indiana and my goal right now is to
finish working on the react native
curriculum and perhaps do some of the
blockchain or help with the blockchain
curriculum in the future hi my name is
Manish I'm a grad student in University
of Cincinnati Ohio my shortened goal is
to graduate in December and hopefully
look for a job as a Java developer and
also I want to contribute more actively
to the free could come back end I've
contributed quite a lot to the front end
and it's it's been interesting to move
towards the back end and also I would
like to be more active in the help rooms
kind of been active yes Steve James
everybody is Jesse from live coding with
Jesse and I think it'd be cool to maybe
do one live stream where I don't mess
anything up and yeah
and for this for the live streams I'd
really love to get to a thousand hours
of streaming I think that would be
awesome we're definitely I think we're
pushing 300 now I haven't counted it in
a while and locally I really want to get
free code camp meetup started I forgot
to tell you I'm from originally from
West Virginia now I live in Ohio but
it's really close to Pittsburgh they oh
they all connect right there so anyway I
think I'm the last one so I hope you all
enjoy this dream
[Music]
all right everyone well yeah oh yeah we
should alright now that you hold this
thing okay thanks to it yeah Matthew
from Toronto I think I
aside from beau actually not know I
think even I have the most content on
our YouTube channel
I of everything on on free code camps
YouTube I have the the highest quantity
the highest hours yeah so I'm basically
running the the live stream for the
music and that's basically just sitting
down there 24 hours a day with me doing
nothing it's sitting in a closet
somewhere on a computer and pumping up
those hours you've got a long way to go
if you're only at 300 hours and yeah if
there's any problems at the stream
tonight I'm the one to blame
hey thank you so much everybody he's
round of applause for everybody who came
all the way out to New York City yeah
[Applause]
and also I just want to thank you all
for everything you're doing it's it's
amazing we were looking at the analytics
for freako camp recently and we are
freako campus
according to similar web which
aggregates all the different places
we're getting something like 15 million
visits a month and a lot of that is to
medium a lot of that is to the core
curriculum to the freako camp guide
we've got quite a few people who've
contributed the guide here and a vast
majority of the things to do in the free
cocaine community are powered by
wonderful volunteers like you all want
wonderful contributors so I just want to
have another big round of applause for
everybody here
[Applause]
and I also want to have a round of
applause for all the free coke camp
contributors who couldn't fly out to New
York City I totally understand it's
expensive to fly out and get a hotel in
New York City
and all the contributors who all the
2018 top contributors who are going to
be at the Dublin event next month and
the Hong Kong event in November so we're
very excited we just confirmed the date
of the Dublin event it's going to be on
September 22nd in downtown Dublin at a
very nice co-working space just like
this very nice co-working space the
rough draft and it's gonna be a ton of
fun and everybody who's watching who has
contributed to freako camp or who's
considering contributing to freako camp
I just want to encourage you to do so so
you can be in the same room with these
amazing people it's such an electrifying
feeling being here so I think at this
point it's worth pointing out that we
have a ton of really good catered food
over here we also have tons of soda and
wine and beer if you're 21 or older and
we're gonna be hanging out here until
about 10:00 10:00 and then if anybody
still feels energy we might go to a
nearby dessert place or cafe or bar some
place that we can still talk it's not
terribly loud but if anybody is up for
that I mean if you flew all the way out
from from Peru or you know from Oslo or
all these far-flung parts of the world
very far from New York City you should
absolutely you should absolutely get the
most of this and tomorrow as promised
there will be a fun run we're going to
run both across the Brooklyn Bridge and
the Manhattan Bridge
so it'sit's about 10k you can total we
can totally have like a walking or walk
run division as well and anybody who
wants can kick it at the cafe where
we're starting and ending and we'll just
chill out afterwards so we've got an
entire weekend of fun relaxing things
for you all to do if you haven't made it
to the World Trade Center Memorial it's
amazing it's pretty new I hadn't seen it
before but we went there yesterday and
it was just the most solemn kind of
humbling experience this this memorial
so it's definitely worth checking out
while you're here in Manhattan if you
haven't been there and so at this point
feel free to just shake your neighbors
hand we have a little badge game find
somebody who has a badge that's the same
color as you and give them a high-five
and yes there are more than one color it
was a random draw and a lot of people
got blue all right
oh so well we'll talk with if you're
wondering about Python we've got some
updates on that we just published an
amazing four and a half hour video which
you can check out it's like a total
python tutorial with code samples and
everything that's on our channel you can
watch that after you watch the stream or
you can walk to write now if you want
just watch it concurrently and we will
have an announcement about a forthcoming
Python curriculum and a little bit
coming from Ethan Arrowwood he's been
working on it for the past few months so
yeah exciting stuff in the pipes we've
got so many exciting things coming up so
stay tuned we're just going to be
hanging out eating and I'm going to walk
around an interview everybody in a
little bit I think right now we can just
let it the camera go and let the mic go
and relax for a minute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
it's a bit high all adjusted afterwards
as well but it's yeah I'm a bit tall for
this I think I think I'm a bit tall for
sitting in this chair and I think
Quincy's gonna be a bit tall as well
what do you what does everybody on the
stream think is this a good height for
me it's definitely a benefit for you all
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
yep
[Music]
whomever whoever looks like they're not
busy well we can go ahead and start with
the man from Oslo himself mark welcome
I'm gonna pull you up on here so
everybody can see your information
because I mean Matthew built this
amazing app why not make heavy use of it
right one second okay
pretty cool huh I just scroll through
here I find mark heard a lot of people
on here we went in and put all the top
contributors just in case people showed
up here we are
so I'm here with mark how do you
pronounce your last name
Ouspensky Terrell Shinseki I'm here with
Mark Trojans he and Mark is the
community organizer for free coking of
Oslo which tell me a little bit about
freako camp also in its history
okay so we have a amazing group of
amazing group of people and also other
admins very active in Oslo we figured
that mondays are the last competitive
they along the week with other events
which are happening more on the end of
the week and during weekends so we
figure that you know most of people
don't have plans at the beginning of the
week so we figured that Monday's are
perfect cause and we are just keeping it
regular and you know the persistence is
the key for our our group so you know
like yeah around year ago there was like
you know meet up with only me or just
two people or three people and now we
have like 15 16 people attending every
every week so that's really a progress
for us that's amazing so 1516 people
coming to your average event how
frequently do you all get together every
week every Monday every Monday okay so
you've got a regular schedule you've
chosen to try to get a set rhythm so
everybody knows hey it's Monday time to
go to free cooking of Oslo
yeah so we have also besides me
we have also very active me admins like
richard middleton ekaterina anikanova
how he understand who are organizing so
if any one of us cannot attend the
Meetup we also have other guys who are
poor there for people who are want to
want to see how does it look like and
how do you how to get into IT awesome
and have very many people within the
community over time have have any of
them gotten jobs as developers yeah so
we have like quite you know small
successes in our in our group so you
know besides you know learning learning
purposes of community as ours there are
also a network effect right so some some
people in our community already work in
in some companies and we know about you
know some job offers within these
companies or some internships that are
appear so we can we can connect people
between companies and between themselves
to try to collaborate and you know when
you are meeting people a lot of people
are quite shy and delaying their job
application right so when we see them on
our meetups every week we are pushing
them to actually start applying and
pushing them due to those people who are
actually in industry and and you know
make that connections as soon as
possible what are some initiatives
you've done outside of just having the
weekly events have you all had any
hackathons or anything like that
yeah we just finished our first
hackathon but it wasn't like traditional
hackathon when you have separate groups
working on separate projects and
competing with each other to win some
prize since we have like mostly
beginners in our group we wanted to show
them how actually the software is being
developed now but so like in teams
because when you are learning you're
primarily to learn on some your your
small projects in local in your local
environment and you don't you don't
cooperate with other people so we wanted
to show them how to cooperate on using
github you know how to split into teams
and one team is responsible for back end
one team is responsible upfront front
end one team is responsible for server
side of the project and we cooperate
together to assemble some working piece
of software
because you know when we are meeting
every every week we spend together like
two three four hours and it's not enough
time to actually build something
constructive from from scratch so we
wanted to dedicate the whole day or
whole weekend so we just made a poll on
Facebook group and we decided that we
just spent the whole Saturday coding and
collaborating on one project and it was
very pleasant surprise that actually we
built some actually moving living fully
functioning piece of software it's not
perfect is it still have a lot of work
to do with in it but it's complete yeah
what kind of software did you build it
was a simple free code camp localizer so
it just allows you to you have them up
and you you are allowed to add your PIN
and add a label to it and you can just
the purpose of it is that you can select
your location when you are spending time
and learning to cover because a lot of
people are learning in cafes and stuff
like that so you can just add your pin
that you are in Starbucks at this and
this location and you are open for
collaboration so other people who are
visiting that website see other people
pins with labels that sounds really cool
the way that people can potentially opt
into hey I'm here I'm gonna be coding
for the next few hours come in hang out
with me and I use the app and I was
really impressed with how robust it was
for the product of a weekend hackathon
it sounds like you had a lot of time and
a lot of energy
you
also help other people who are less
experienced to help them to get their
feet wet right so some pair programming
was was involved because you know it
wasn't like all the participants were
working separately we were doing pieces
of the project in pairs or in in groups
of three people so you know we had like
these kind of more experienced people
responsible for the particular area and
we were trying to assemble it with help
of with other people who are involved we
were involved so it was it was nice idea
to try and we all participants I enjoyed
it so I think we will try to do it again
awesome well aside from doing hackathons
do you all have any other goals for the
near future for what freako camp also is
going to try to tackle and the last half
of 2018 we started collaborating with
other companies that are in based in
Oslo so they're the startup community in
also itself is quite rapidly growing
because you know you know agen and
Norwegian industry is based primarily in
oil in recent years but they are noticed
they notice the you know the future that
is ahead of us and they are trying to
switch from elbow oil based industry
into IT so they are investing a lot of
money and a lot of resources to to try
to support the local initiatives like
that so we are working with we are
collaborating with Explorer HQ which is
a like like community and half of
companies collaborating on various
projects and also other hubs and and
startup incubators - you know just to be
in the environment and know what is
happening in order
awesome well how about you personally
tell me a little bit about your career
trajectory and your near term goals okay
so I I work in IT like for ten years
but on management side so right now I'm
software a project manager in one of the
companies in Oslo but I you know I felt
constantly that impostor syndrome that I
don't have in a full understanding of
the things that I'm responsible for
that's why I started to learning to code
to expand my texting technical skills
and to understand it better so you know
and I also have some ideas for for my
own projects and I can either pay
someone to build it for me or I can
learn that skills and build it by
yourself right that's the right way to
think of it so how long have you been
coding for I think like regular for
around the year because well you know I
work full time so I can dedicate some
limited time for it's just like evenings
and some part of weekends so it's not
going very fast but I'm trying to make
some gradual progress in learning yeah
absolutely learning the code is a
marathon it's not a sprint and it sounds
like you're approaching that with that
mindset so have you yet had a chance to
apply any of your coding skills to your
IT management job yeah like I started I
got interested with that more technical
skills when I tried to approach our
developers in my previous project and
ask them for some data and I felt that
like the things that I'm asking them is
very simple and I can actually grab that
data if I if I learn some basics of its
SQL so I just started learning SQL to be
able to dig into in our data and find
the answers that I want to their own
together so even as a technical project
manager you've managed to turn around
and immediately as an IT manager you
you've managed to immediately apply some
of your technical skills
on the job yep yeah that's the plan -
you know just make it make that
transition quite credible that's great
and the fact that you've been able to do
all this without taking any additional
risk you haven't left your job you
haven't taken any sort of pay cuts
you're just doing the same thing you
were doing before but now you're moving
in a more technical direction that's
that's the idea well I think that I'm
gonna encourage everybody to jump on
Twitter and follow mark I think that he
is a very inspiring person within the
freako camp community
I've really enjoyed using your hackathon
project I am very interested in
Scandinavia in general I think a lot of
America is looking at Scandinavia as
potentially being a model of going
forward feel invited and drop by
whenever you're in yeah and I absolutely
hope to visit Scandinavia in the next
year or two we have a lot of free
cooking of study groups up there and
yeah keep doing what you're doing it's
amazing and hope you'll join us soon and
well you'll be in Europe and yeah
because we have like the also a group is
just one of them we have a couple of
other groups in in other cities in
Norway but they're all as I tried to
look for other groups there are also
multiple groups in whole Europe so so
there are definitely communities similar
to ours great well we need to have some
sort of freak ok wide Europe summit but
we're gonna have an event in Dublin is
there any chance you'll be able to make
it to the free cooking of Dublin event
I'll try I think maybe Richard Richard
militant would try to reach it one of
our mid admits in Oslo but you know I I
just I I'm not sure if I will be able to
make it financially but you know if I
would and only have an opportunity I
would definitely join them great Wow and
just for some context Richard Melton he
is a another top contributor who will be
at the Dublin event and he runs free
coke games Instagram page which you
haven't checked it out yet check it out
instagram.com slash free coke camp and a
lot of the photos on there from free
coking of Oslo right yeah
content from our journey and from middle
richard richard experiences so and he as
i see the he runs it we have huge
success because you know the the amount
of activity there is quite quite amazing
compared to other similarly similar
topics there well thank you so much mark
from flying all the way out to new york
city and joining us thank you for
leading the pre-code camp also study
group and thanks for thinking about all
these new ways that people can
collaborate in real time and learn
together Thank you Thank You Queen C
[Music]
alright Cheers
all right hey Megan welcome Megan I'm
gonna pull up your information here if
anybody's interested in and learning a
little bit more about Megan your your
last name is pronounced Malloy alright
perfect
well Megan you've been involved in free
code camp here in New York City for
quite a while
could you describe your involvement so
far so when I first joined free code
camp it was in part because I wanted to
learn how to code I had been doing a
little bit of coding in Visual Basic
already and wanted to do something that
was a little bit more relevant for you
know mm and I also wanted to get to know
some new people because I had just moved
to New York City so it seemed like a
good way to get some learning as well as
get to meet some people so I started
going to the free code camp meetups and
working through the curriculum it really
helps like keep me honest keep me going
through cuz every time I go to meetups
everybody wants to check on you and see
like how far have you gotten and if
you're still doing the same projects you
were doing two weeks ago it feels a
little bad to say that's other people so
it's a good way to make sure that I was
making progress and as well it's get
help with other people and then as I got
more and more confident also helped to
go and to talk to other people who are
working through the same challenges and
then have to explain
to them as well and really solidify that
knowledge so that's how I got sort of
first involved in the meet up so I was
just going as a student and then after a
few months Victoria and Mike were
looking for somebody to run another
meet-up on weekends so I volunteered for
that and started running a Saturday
meetup for the last two years but
attendance is sort of mixed because
people have things to do on Saturdays so
no I'm just kind of doing like pop-up
meetups so whenever I have some time
I'll say I'm going to get this place in
two hours if anybody else wants to meet
up there and then we can just code
together on whatever we're working on
that day awesome and these pop-up
meetups how long you been doing that and
and how has it been so far what have you
in your experiences with them so it's so
far I've only met with a couple of
people for the pop-up once I started
doing it in March because until March I
was doing just regular Saturday meetups
so I think just for my schedule
personally it's much more convenient for
me to say like here's a time when I
would like to dedicate to coding and can
really focus on that more rather than
having a set time and I think it works a
little better for other people as well
because it's not the same time every day
so you can get different people to come
to it because they're all available at
different times as well and we can
change up the location and so I'm more
variety for other people to potentially
attend and much more convenient for my
personal schedule yeah that sounds great
and how about your own learning have you
you've been learning a little bit on
your own as time permits yeah so I did
the whole front end certificate through
free code camp and then after that I got
a little sidetracked I wasn't sure what
I wanted to do it part of the course on
Ruby on Rails through udemy I started
working through a little bit of the
backend stuff on free code camp and
started learning d3 at the same time
this year I was able to finish the
course I was doing in d3 through you to
me so that was that it felt good to get
that other way and now at this point I'm
sort of trying to decide on exactly what
I want to learn because I've been sort
of learning a little bit of different
things still working with a little bit
of d3 I picked up a book on data science
so I really musn't get focused so but
definitely a lot more learning to be had
yeah and so learning data visualization
you're learning a little bit about data
science do you think that's the
direction you might be interested in
going yeah so right now I'm a data
analyst so it's sort of related to my
current career and I think ultimately
I'd like to do something more like data
journalism like the stuff that 5:38 does
where you can have interactive
visualizations as well as some research
backing it up and telling a story using
data ok and for people who are watching
and they're interested in finding like a
really good data visualization that's
really impressive and kind of highlights
the power of data journalism which is
still pretty nascent I've been looking
at some amazing stuff coming out of New
York Times which is where d3 was created
by my boss doc what would be a good data
journalism piece that they could Google
that they might be able to get a better
feel for the field from so a lot of the
stuff that 5:38 does is really great and
their election stuff they have some
interactive articles being I think the
New York Times runs the upshot which is
more data journalism focus so some of
their stuff is really great and I think
they have some interesting ways to
really engage readers like when you're
scrolling through a page it'll load like
a new piece to a chart so it'll tell you
about the factors that contribute to
global warming and you'll see like
here's carbon emissions from cars and
then you scroll down the page and you're
reading about carbon emissions from cars
and then
this other layer of the chart pops in
and it's like airplanes when they tell
you about airplanes so really sort of
engaging the reader with some animation
and in the chart as you go through the
page awesome whoa our data visualization
section on free code camp is still
pretty rough we have a lot of
information on using d3 and SVG and
stuff like that but I think in terms of
applied data visualization as a skill
and some basic principles that that
people should apply when they're trying
to build visualizations that is
definitely ripe for expansion so if
you're interested in finding an area of
freako camp that you could potentially
contribute to in the future
certainly the curriculum would benefit
from your passion in that field you're
currently working as a data analyst you
said and a lot of people are kind of
confused about the difference between
doing data analysis and doing actual
data science how would you describe the
difference between the two fields as far
as you understand them so in my
experience I think data science is a
little bit more on the backend doing a
lot of calculations math and writing up
algorithms to try to segment an audience
or something along those lines and data
analysis is here's all the data you have
in front of us now tell us what this
means to a human person and then in my
personal experience it's been more like
a business analysis so if you're looking
at stats for different marketing
campaigns how do you relatively compare
how well each one did and whether you
should continue that campaign
if you were to hypothetically let's say
I'm you suddenly had you were really
good at data visualization you were
really good with the you had strong
toolset you had learned plenty of
additional math beyond what you
currently know and you just go ahead and
tackle any topic with data's journalism
what what area would you be interested
in exploring I've been really interested
in investigating crime statistics
specifically since I moved to New York
from Chicago I really wanted to compare
crime stats between the two cities for
specific neighborhoods in each city
because the area I lived in in Chicago
it wasn't the best area but rent was
cheap and I was willing to accept that
level of risk and so I wanted to find an
area in New York where it would be sort
of similarly safe so that I could sort
of minimize my rent price while still
being comfortable in the neighborhood
and it's really really hard to compare
crime stats between cities because they
have all these different categorizations
for how they label crimes so I really
like to dig more into that and try to
find a way to standardize that a little
better and make something that would be
useful for people who are moving between
major cities are there any data
visualizations or any interactive ways
to access data that you've built so far
that you'd be interested in in sharing
like anything that's online that people
could check out yeah so I do have a
website that's Meghan solocom and I have
a couple small blog posts on there one
of them is about visual basics code and
one of them was looking at statistics on
whether treaties trade off with bills in
Congress when like there's this massive
bipartisanship that we've seen so like
maybe Congress would be passing more
treaties because they can't get bills
approved so may as well try to do
something symbolic turns out there
doesn't seem to be any sort of trade off
um but I wrote that up anyway because I
think a lot of things that are published
nowadays you only want to publish
something if there's flashy findings but
we really need to make a move more to
publishing things that say oh actually
nothing happened here anyway
so that's that's on my site as well
that's great night
just just to completely agree with what
you said I think it'd be great if I open
the news and things that were obvious
but true that people had just confirmed
you know complied with people's general
worldview and sense of common sense if
we just had more headlines like guess
what you know someone's oh really is the
case you know I I agree we do you think
that certainly within science the drive
to find novel and counterintuitive
findings has buried a lot of other
important findings that just conform to
people's expectations yeah I think
there's definitely a lot of studies that
just aren't as sometimes aren't even
published because somebody thought that
their findings weren't worthwhile and
from what I've read this is actually a
huge issue because that means that if
you haven't published that somebody else
might go repeat your work and then
that's so much wasted time within the
whole community that they could have
spent looking at something else instead
of repeating something that you already
found out awesome well what are your so
you're learning some additional data
science stuff you have picked up a lot
of additional libraries and things like
that what would you say your near-term
goals are for the next 18 months so I'm
trying to get a little more organized
and figure out what the best process for
learning is right now my thought is if I
could combine into some sort of
recurring format if I could learn a data
science concept find a data set that I
want to work with and then apply that
data concept with that data science
concept to that data set visualize it in
d3 and then post a blog post that would
be the ideal workflow for me I just need
to sort of figure out a cadence that
would actually be achievable and whether
or not that's too much stuff because
maybe I shouldn't bother with the data
science concepts just yet and I should
just focus on taking a data set and
doing something in d3 so I need to find
what the right balance is to actually
make it achievable while also still
learning something as far as freako camp
New York City your efforts there first
of all thank you so much for your years
of taking the time to help people in the
community learn to code and bring them
together what are your ambitions on that
front do you have any ideas for how we
could make the pre-cooking of New York
City more cohesive or or get people
coming out more regularly so I think one
of the things we've been talking about
for a while is having more sort of
specialized meetup so we would have a
certain topic that we're dressing like
Mike mentioned using it or if we could
have a hackathon like Victoria mentioned
something like that where there's a
specific task at hand I think that would
probably garner a little bit more
response
I think we also need to work on reaching
out through different channels because
right now we're pretty much only posting
things on Facebook and I know there's a
lot of people in the free code scam
community who aren't on Facebook so we
need to sort of figure out where are
those people how can we communicate with
them okay great and even though we use
Facebook is kind of critical
infrastructure for our study groups
Facebook's group functionalities pretty
mature and it's well built and
maintained we are hoping to have kind of
like some better functionality right on
freako campus especially for people that
don't want to use Facebook which I
totally understand these days are there
any features that you think just off the
top of your head that would we could
potentially build that would make that
more likely to be a success I'm sort of
like alerting I would like a pop-up that
would tell you when something was about
to happen within X hours in your area I
think that would be really useful I
think even for me there's so many
different sections a pretty good camp
that it's hard to keep track of all of
them so like I didn't even know that the
guy it existed until yesterday when you
talked about it and so sort of that
discoverability aspect definitely needs
to be a focus when we're thinking about
alerting for events because if there's
just a whole new section where there's
just this is the event section then that
might be hard for people to find and get
to know but I know push notifications
can also get really annoying so have to
find the right balance there yeah well
we're gonna work we're gonna try to find
like a good kind of equilibrium where
we're not bugging people too much but we
are giving them some insight into like
the different sections and different
contributions going on and right now
what we're doing on the YouTube channel
I'm hoping that a lot of the people who
watch this both live and after-the-fact
will realize oh wow there's a vibrant
New York City group oh there's a data
visualization section you know data
journalism is a thing a lot of people
aren't even Flair with that concept and
it's so new so taking the time to talk
with people like you Megan makes a huge
difference I'm gonna pull up your
information and put it on the screen
again
everybody I strongly recommend you you
track down
Megan Malloy if you just google Megan
Malloy NYC well it would be a good way
for people to find you it there I think
I'm one of two people with this name so
hopefully I think my website pops up
within the first page of Google find out
alright everybody check out Megan Malloy
I bumped her name up and thank you again
Megan for everything you're doing
for one person yeah absolutely
Greg's here yeah Ethan first have a seat
man go is this sound coming through his
pretty much okay perfect
[Music]
hey how's the audio everybody just
message in the chat if the audio is good
okay cool
[Music]
[Music]
it looks like it may not be advancing
though
awesome thank you for confirming that
everybody watching around the world so
I'm here with a very special contributor
I'm gonna pull your name up just so
everybody can see your Twitter handle
and everything I'm doing this manually
with this amazing tool that Matthew the
a/v extraordinaire creative Ethan
Arrowwood welcome to the live stream and
you hail from Boston you are a student
there an undergraduate student yes yes
undergrad student at Wentworth Institute
of Technology a little bit about your
currently you're an intern
yes and yeah tell us a little more yes
so I am an intern at Microsoft in
Cambridge I am on the commercial
software engineering team and it's a
incredible opportunity a very unique
internship so rather than working on a
specific product or a specific service
that microsoft offers such as asher or
office i work in it's like almost a
hackathon kind of way where we work with
some of the top as your clients and if
they have any sort of data sets they
want analyzed or worked on or they have
problems they want solutions to or new
applications Microsoft will assemble a
crew developers from the CSE team and we
go out and we build something really
cool with them for a week or two weeks
and then when we're all done we hand it
off to them we show them how to use it
we provide documentation and a lot of
what we do right
gets open-source or at least we talk
about it we write blog posts about it
I'm based in Cambridge like I said but I
actually was here in New York this past
week at the New York office working on a
very incredible project doing some
docker and kubernetes as well as some
react code
and it's been the best internship I've
ever I could have ever asked for
awesome well how did you get the
internship yeah so um Twitter actually I
was
I love tweeting about tech free code
camp especially and contributing to open
source was what really caught the eye of
my now manager he was also an alumni
from my university Wentworth and when he
found me on Twitter he reached out we
connected and through that connection I
got into the interview process and then
during the interview process for this
team specifically they were really
impressed with what I did in regards to
open source as a college student and so
from that they I made it through
thankfully and now I'm having a very
great experience that's great so just by
doing what you love contributing the
opens horse sharing information you
caught the eye of Microsoft did you
apply for the internship or did they
reach out to you and ask you to apply
how did that go down yeah so I put my
application in online like anyone else
would
and then once my application was in
their system and my name was in their
system I don't know the exact specifics
but I did get to go visit the office and
my manager his name is Ben and Ben did
bring me in and he showed me around and
I don't know exactly what connections he
made but I don't know if it's exactly a
coincidence that I wound up on his team
literally working for him so there was
definitely something there that helped
up but the first step if you do want to
work at Microsoft or get an internship
there just apply online it's the first
step for everybody and they have a great
program for interns expecially
University students and even not they
are always looking for new people so
definitely apply and put your name out
there awesome you have point a varied
background I have I've had the pleasure
of knowing you for many years now that's
where your involvement with the free
cocaine community
among the many things you do we often
joke about freako camp having a bunch of
camp counselors that help Stuart the the
nonprofit and the open source repo but
you are a literal camp counselor yes I
am a literal camp counselor I have been
for three summers now and I recommend
that everyone takes an opportunity to go
and join nature and the outdoors more
specifically Vermont is a beautiful
state here in the United States if you
ever do you get a chance to visit I
recommend coming through the state also
New Hampshire's got the white Malins or
the presidential range beautiful places
the hike in canoe and definitely don't
take for granted the outdoors getting a
set of you know even as much as a
programmer I am and the amount of coding
I do I always take an opportunity to get
outside whether it's a walk or a run in
Boston or a day hike in the mountains
nearby it's definitely a thing and also
summer camp send your kids to summer
camp go to summer camp maybe apply to
become a camp counselor it's one of the
best things you can possibly do and
you'll learn a lot of things and a lot
of things that you can apply to your
career your learning experiences your
learning process it all comes from camp
so yeah awesome well that is quite an
endorsement of spending time outdoors
and helping kids gonna get their
bearings in nature so thanks for all
that you do for the next generation as a
camp counselor and also thanks again for
you know we're gonna take some of the
some of the terminology from camping
we're gonna create a bunch of badges for
free coconut we've been meaning to do
this from the very beginning you know
Tenderfoot
the vag or something like that so I
think that there are so many ideas from
camping because camping is a fun
communal experience like contributing to
open source it's not super competitive
generally it's just hanging out
reflecting and spending time in nature
and and I see a lot of similarities
between the pace and the general vibe of
camping and learning to code so on the
subject of learning the code you have
created a number of videos for the free
Koki beaut Tube channel which have done
very well and lots of people have
benefited from them and said positive
things about them you've also written
some articles the medium publication and
now you're embarking on the biggest
adventure yet in your free code camp
contributor shift why don't you tell us
a little bit of a bet I can't wait all
right so my biggest adventure yet is the
Python curriculum it has been a little
it's been an idea since the beginning
but it became more into a fishing about
a year ago we tried kind of fizzled out
but we made some great you know
fundamental foundational progress and
then this year due to I forget who it
was but there was some incredible Python
curriculum that was uploaded on the
YouTube channel and because of the
attention from that we realized the free
code camp community really wants it
wants Python and wants a in-browser
experience just like they currently have
for JavaScript and all the other web
tech think web tech things so right now
I am working on the learn platform of a
fork of learn and making it so it can
support Python in the browser just like
you would how we currently run you know
write the code run the tests get
feedback and all that and earn
our earnest certification through a you
know step-by-step curriculum so with all
of that said I am working hard on
getting that foundation set and then
once that foundation is set we're gonna
take a lot of the aspects of what's
currently there for the JavaScript side
of things and we're going to try to
convert that to Python and then once we
convert those JavaScript fundamentals
and challenges over the Python we will
have the first iteration of a Python
curriculum and then from that there's
some very
future-looking ideas like doing things
like more intensive data science machine
learning AI and a lot of the things that
you know a lot of people are really
interested in but don't even know where
to start and what what library are you
currently using that looks most
promising for running Python client side
in the browser so we're currently using
bright on it's a essentially as it is an
embrasure Python editor or at least
interpreter we're gonna use the mónaco
editor to still get the Python content
for the code from the users and then
we're gonna pass that through the breath
on which will run the Python code that
you write along with whatever tests we
load in the backend and then it'll work
very similar to how the current learning
platform works with JavaScript and the
way we kind of retrieve the j/s and run
it the same way and breath on is easy to
remember because this browser Python
Python and you also mentioned Monaco
Monaco for those of you who haven't
heard of it yet it is an in-browser
editor that is a basically vs code
Visual Studio code but it's running in a
browser it's not like the full IDE but
it's close it's got a lot of the key
functionality like to have completion
and things like that
at Microsoft what have you touched any
of the tack of you have you made any
contributions to any of these big open
source projects they have there yeah
so I wish I could say yes but I haven't
really made direct open source
contributions yet but some of the things
I have gotten to do include doing a full
stack web application we use Postgres
database we use flask Python API for the
backend we used react and d3 on the
front-end I got to learn a lot about
SVG's and how those work we learned
about authentication and then more
recently I've been focusing on docker
kubernetes and that whole that whole
ecosystem and it's it really blows my
mind right now what what that all is and
if you're looking to step up your game
from I guess more than the basics or
that intermediate level and you're like
what can I do next I really encourage
you to look into docker and kubernetes
there's a lot of resources out there and
it's really wild what you can do with it
and it might seem silly at first and it
might seem almost like why would I do
all this extra work or something I can
already do like natively but once you
keep getting into it and learning some
of them more verbose things you can do
with it
it's a extremely powerful and it will be
the next generation of web tech or just
tech in general maybe not necessarily
web so and freako camp uses docker for
several of our services and we're
looking into using kubernetes for some
things as well so what are some of your
ambitions I mean your hands are pretty
full with the Python curriculum Anna an
internship it and Microsoft and
finishing up school how much school you
have left by the way one year okay
so I guess it's probably hard to think
even a year out with so many balls in
the air but what are your near-term
goals
Ethan of course so I absolutely love my
team at Microsoft and I hope some of
them get to see this video because I do
want them to know just how incredible
the team is and I do see a future there
I would love I would love a future there
but I also have some entrepreneurial
ambitions I am it I am involved in an
entrepreneurial Center at Wentworth it's
called accelerate we are currently
working throughout Boston and
working on some really cool things I
hope to share on my Twitter if you
follow me on Twitter you'll see all the
updates from that and then on top of
that so either by running the program or
also coming up with my own
entrepreneurial idea I definitely see
that in my future but more stable at the
moment I think I'm gonna keep doing the
open source I really again I really
enjoy Microsoft and I would love to find
a career there and so yeah I think I
think keeping it keeping it simple for
my my ambitions at the moment you know I
love Boston New York cities great too
but I do love Boston so I'll stick
around there for a little more a little
while longer so just Boston is one of
those cities that you just have to visit
if you're in the United States there's
so much history there if somebody were
hypothetically let's say they just had
like a 10 hour layover embossing during
the day when everything was open what is
the one thing you would say they
absolutely have to go and do in Boston
all right this is coming from the coding
side of me but there's a coffee chain
called pavement coffee you need to go
there
they usually have seasonal drinks in
fall they're seasonal options are the
best things ever they have this like fig
latte so go into the city find a
pavement I believe there's seven or
eight of them besides pavement
definitely go to the Charles River it is
beautiful you can walk on either side of
it the Cambridge or the Boston side and
you get a beautiful skyline either
whichever way you look at it and yeah I
think those two be up there and my two
favorite things to do or to must do
things if you're in Boston for 10 hours
Ethan has been such a pleasure talking
to you man we're very pumped about the
Python curriculum that you've been
working on these past few months we're
extremely excited about your awesome
videos where you explain concepts like
react which are on the YouTube channel
check them out and I encourage everybody
to follow Ethan on Twitter I'm just
gonna pull up his
for here one more time as Arrowwood tech
this guy's going places and want you all
to be there to see his trajectory
message if anyone does connect with me I
love talking and I'll be happy to talk
with anybody about anything whether it
be tech whether it be about traveling
adventuring camping diversity and
solving those problems I am involved in
that on my campus and it's something I
am passionate about so really reach out
I love talking to you Mike I believe my
Twitter messages are open so feel free
to come and chat at any time and I'd
love to help you out on anything you do
do you need thank you so much even
Cheers
[Music]
all right and next we have a very
special guest coming from Carlsbad
California she is a longtime editor of
free cocaine medium publication Toni
Toni you have probably and how many
articles you guess that you may have
edited over time maybe 15,000 seems that
way yeah it's a lot it's it's hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of articles
that Tony has edited I'm gonna go ahead
and pop her information here up on the
screen for everybody to check her check
her out Tony tell me a little bit about
medium and what drew you to the platform
well when I first began at free code
camp I was advised to get the medium
publication and I found that all the
articles taught me something and those
that didn't it was okay I still learned
so when I was given the opportunity to
edit for some of my favorite authors I
just had to go for it and I'm glad I did
because I'm always learning
yeah and that that passion for learning
that followed you through life give us a
little bit about your background and
what made you such a lifelong learner
and so curious about all these different
topics well I've been wanting some code
since I first learned that it existed I
have been self-taught over the years but
I didn't have a real curriculum to go
with which is why I love free code so I
have some good teachers who have helped
me learn but there was still things I
wanted to continue to do I have found
that as myself as a teenager I did not
believe in myself
and so when I was teaching the SAT
classes I was able to encourage the
students to learn and to go to the
College of the choice and that reminded
me that I should be doing the same thing
and so anything that I can do to make
the world better
the team's better and myself I think
it's just great and the fact that
pre-code camp in the article I read was
helping nonprofit organizations always
just an added bonus
so you're somebody who has lived a lot
of places in fact I think you live in
two different places you live in both
Honolulu and Carlsbad which do not
familiar with California geography just
north of San Diego is that correct yeah
so what's it like traveling a lot and
bouncing back and forth between those
locations you just flew across the u.s.
to come to New York City well I don't
think I'll do that one again it was a
long journey
I love Honolulu and someday I'm going
home Carlsbad is good to us and as long
as my husband's happy there or stay
there but we both have our reasons for
where we like to live
and as far as the travel itself it's not
as much fun as it used to be but I still
enjoy seeing new places and meeting new
people and tell me a little bit about
your husband is he watching right now I
hope so he said he would he's great his
he's an LMS administrator corporate
trainer and designer for LMS systems he
also believes in higher education he we
went to Honolulu because he wanted to go
back to school and I chose you I chose
University of Hawaii so he said okay
then when he graduated from there he
went to Honolulu a hpu Hawaii Pacific
University got his master's from there
and now he's pursuing his EDD so higher
education is important to both of us me
because I never really went to college
and him because he has me lesson so
that's heavy so it sounds like he's
quite a learned man and it sounds like
Yeltsin was quite a bit about technology
in general and has that been a big
driver for you and continuing your
learning about technology actually no
I'm the one who's driving him he just
learned HTML he had a spout between
about between contracts so he learned
CSS in HTML meanwhile I he'd been
watching me by with Simon Says
tic-tac-toe and so he thought this is
ridiculous but he was very proud of me
every time I did something right
so he
needed for the position we wanted to
know my sequel so he learned it and then
and I knew it opened up now he's
learning JavaScript so he told me today
and you just signed up for free code
camp as a camper I the guy who's writing
in this thing that's great well I'm
thrilled that he's learning in and you
know you're able to kind of guide him to
a large extent and help him with his
learning as well so have you all
considered maybe building a project
together yes we do have a project we'd
like to build and until it all comes
together I can't talk about it okay well
can you give us even hints about what
that project might be about it's about
helping others learn and and it's gonna
be really great and it's hopefully being
with Aloha so you you've edited so many
of the articles that a lot of the people
watching this who have read on the free
code camp medium publication we have
about a hundred twenty-five thousand
people who read the medium publication
every day now what is one article that
you edited that just you're very proud
that you got to be a part of
that's difficult because there are a lot
of them I've had people ask me when I
when I when I Twitter that is that if
I've done those and the truth is I have
I think that my favorite one my favorite
one was by one of my favorite
programmers actually and his was how to
buy a laptop for beginners because about
the time that came out I had just
started editing for you and I had
already seen his articles before so I
jumped on it was like yes this is my
favorite and he speaks so clearly to the
person who doesn't understand technology
and helps them to see this is what you
need this is why you need it and it just
felt like that was that was something I
was a part of and it was in the very
beginning which is probably why it
stayed with you so long
great I think I know wait article you're
talking about and I'm gonna reach out to
them and make sure that he knows that
you have such warm feelings for his
article his guide to buying a laptop I
thought that was a profound ly useful
guide myself so what would you say your
your workflow is like free code camp is
completely remote where asynchronous
generally we have a Trello board where
you can go and the editor team which is
pretty small so it's a pretty intimate
Bunch pony and a B and a few other key
people edit virtually every article
every article that gets published in
free go camp is edited by somebody like
Tony
who
cares about quality and style and wants
to make sure that the article is in the
best possible light what's your workflow
like when you sit down to edit like
what's your what's your environment like
where do you edit just tell us a little
bit like okay I'm gonna go edit now what
happens when you make that decision
first I have to find an article I like I
need to be interested in it that's not
really true sometimes Abby will say hey
someone I need someone to do this
immediately and if it looks like I can
handle it
I like the challenge of English as a
Second Language because my my skill sets
in grammar and so that makes me feel
good about it but I really like the ones
that just reach out and say hey isn't
this something you're interested in you
know you're doing a react thing that you
want to read about reaction so I'll
decide on the article for whatever
reason and of course we have to put our
avatar on it to let everybody else know
and so once I grab it I try to finish
within 24 hours
because I think it's important the
author's waiting for us you know but
also because if I'm entrusting you
enough to call on it I need to go
through it so the main thing I look for
is the grammar itself the tenses whether
it happened yesterday or will happen in
the future
basic typos and lates leaks are really
important to me so I'll check every link
in the article to make sure it goes to
where the office says it's going to and
I'll also make sure the JavaScript is
spelled with a capital J and a capital S
that is one that like JavaScript we
think oh and also github right
everybody's follow the GI T uppercase G
ith UV or no uppercase at all right
that's right yes you smell correctly
nodejs I'm still kind of confused about
so yeah I generally do just uppercase n
OD es Jas and but some people will do
note uppercase J upper cases I think
angularjs is actually the proper way to
do it is angularjs whereas most of the
libraries like react GIS you just do a
dot lowercase JSP and that's sort of the
rule I follow - so after that I pretty
much I hand it over to Abby who is our
final editor and hopefully she'll say
yeah this is great we publish it without
fixing too many things yeah do you find
it helpful to have someone like a be
like give you pointers and stuff on your
editing she doesn't actually do that
very often anymore I think that your
editor guide that you put out for us I
follow that still you know I know we're
not supposed to it takes two ton of time
but it doesn't take too much time if
you're doing it right it's incorporated
properly so I follow your editorial guy
a bee fortunately thinks the same way I
do yeah well if Abby's not like pointing
out different things that probably means
there's nothing to point out so I would
say that's testament to you and
expanding your skills as an editor and
also getting better at taking our style
guide and interpreting it and applying
it thank you thank you
well Tony you are so prolific and I just
want to drive home to everybody who's
watching this is one of the very most
prolific editors on the freako camp
medium publication the articles that
she's edited have probably reached tens
of millions of people at this point it's
a lot of people who are reading these
articles and using them to learn to code
so everybody who's watching I strongly
encourage you to to follow Tony on
Twitter and also just to look out for
her she writes some articles of her own
tell us a little bit about the most
recent article you wrote I'm an outreach
intern and outreach org works with women
and underrepresented to tech people and
places us in internships with a stipend
so they pay my way here thank you very
much but as part of the program I have
to blog I have to write an article every
two weeks so I've been on my outreaching
journey since April and it's about to
end unfortunately but but they say that
you know am i from us to be able to
forward
but what I've been writing lately is all
about outreach II and all I'm doing in
my internship and how I'm learning and
how sometimes I'm not but it's like I'm
very proud of it and I have to see what
my editors actually edit them Z and
Charlie they don't go back a courser
who's doing it
but they gave me good feedback and of
course now he always says give me more
information please
so she's teaching me how to write that's
great and outreach he is just a
wonderful program specifically to get a
lot more women in the technology and
provide them with internships through
Mozilla is that right I'm not really
sure about that I do know they had me at
liver health through the EHR
documentation and the reason that I
received that internship was because I
was an editor on medium and I used
everything I knew great so yet another
instance of people who are contributing
to freako camp who benefit in all kinds
of ways while helping the developer
community so you know that's a great
byproduct of your contribution that you
were able to obtain these fairly
competitive and very generous internship
programs
I just want to say one thing free code
camp is awesome but the authors of the
medium digest are the ones who make it
work so whether you're talking on a as a
beginner level or an advanced level
send us your articles we'd love to get
at them yeah thank you so much Tony you
helped so many of our writers really
shine especially our non-native English
speaker writers I frequently hear for
people that are so grateful that to have
somebody who understands you know
grammar really well and is you know has
a background in English language and
editing and things like that and so it
makes a huge difference it helps them
put their feet forward people get jobs
all the time they get freelance gigs
they get internships they get they start
companies around things that they've
initially written about on the free coke
a medium publication and a big part of
that is because you take the time to
really make sure that they are in the
best possible light thank you well they
work hard to get there so the least we
can do is make them look good all right
thank you again Tony have a wonderful
evening and thanks again for flying out
here from Carlsbad California to hang
out with us in New York City
[Music]
yeah I'm ready
[Music]
sorry cute for me I'm sorry that I
kicked ever my girl oh I don't want that
bag in your way
Oh perfect thank you Tony no I'm fine
thank you all right you know when I was
a kid I had a lot of brothers and we'd
always joked it liked it it wasn't a
family meal until somebody knocked a
drink over all right I'm here with
Jennifer bland I'm gonna put put your
information up on screen for everybody's
benefit I am so thrilled that you made
it out from Atlanta we are so graced by
your presence here have learned so much
from you over the past year year and a
half that you've been contributing at
least a year I don't remember exactly
when we you know I first talked but your
videos your articles people constantly
cite them as being instrumental in their
efforts to get jobs and to learn more
about programming and just to say
motivator thank you very much I'm
excited to be here excited to be part of
this amazing group of people you know
I'll give you a little bit of background
about myself I used to be a Lotus Notes
programmer so when I tell people that
always ask people raise your hand if
you've ever used Lotus Notes ever a lot
of people raise their hands and then
like raise your hand if your company
still uses Lotus Notes nobody does and
that explains why I actually got out of
programming many many years ago and I
started working on an internet marketing
business on the side and it grew and I
retired at the age of 51 and I was
retired for about a year and a half and
one day walked into Barnes and Noble
picked up a book on JavaScript
programming on the clearance rack spent
a month working through it learning it
and then it was like stay unemployed
passion for programming and that passion
for programming ran one out and I
decided to become unemployed
I mean unretired and go back into work
and I did a coding boot camp that is so
prevalent today and after my coding boot
camp I graduated got a job working at
CNN in Atlanta and that's when I started
working with free code camp because you
know you could only learn so much in
three months and a coding boot camp and
I wanted to greatly improve my cutting
skills and so I'd literally in six
months when they you had the original
curriculum went through and did every
one of those certificates got to work on
one of the nonprofit organizations for
you know for crimes against women and
that was a great experience for doing
that and now what I'd like to do is be
able to give back and contribute to
others well what are some ways that
you've been giving back to developers
and progress people who are
transitioning into the field the number
one way that I give back is I write a
lot of articles like you said mentioned
earlier because I like to write articles
from her perspective of I used to be a
rookie programmer and I wanted to be
able to read something and understand it
and be able to apply what I learned from
that material there are a lot of
articles that are super technical and
they were like be above somebody's head
or they would explain it but they
wouldn't cover everything and some it
had those gaps in there and people were
like I don't understand this
so I like to write from a perspective of
how I would have liked to have learned
when I was learning and I think that's
been very beneficial to people for them
to be able to see it and to understand
it then the other thing that I've done
to give back is
so many people are learning how to
program great for everybody doing that I
encourage everybody to do that but then
once they've learned it and they go out
and they start interviewing to get their
first job in tag and they're not quite
ready for that experience because it's
so different from any job you will ever
interview for in any career and they
feel like a you know a deer in
headlights when they experience it for
the first time so I created a whole
series of videos that basically showed
people this is what your interview
process is going to be like here are
actual interview questions that people
have asked me others have been asked and
then I just sat there on the whiteboard
and answered them exactly like what you
would see in an interview so that it
would benefit them and help out and now
after I've done that I've go through and
helped out being an editor on on the
medium publication right now so try to
do somewhere between 10 and 14 articles
a week that I edit and contribute from
that standpoint thank you so much for
editing all these articles in addition
to writing them I mean when you write
the article you're in the spotlight when
you're editing an article you're behind
the scenes just helping people in the
background put their best foot forward
on with their own work you've spent a
lot of time and energy specifically
helping people with the somewhat jarring
and unpredictable job application
process and I think one of the things
that surprises people the most when they
go ahead and apply for jobs is just that
they have to apply for a lot of jobs and
it's pretty it's in the skills you
employ in a job interview are very
different from what you would employ and
you're actually doing the job due to the
way that the job processes application
process is a wall can you talk a little
bit about the things that you think are
if you had just a few high-level tips
for people when they're applying for
jobs
absolutely the first tip that I would
give people even if you have some of the
skill sets they list in a job
description but not all of them apply
you don't need to have all of them apply
every job that I've had since I came out
of a cutting boot camp I didn't have a
hundred percent of the skill sets but I
still got the job number two would be
even if you don't think that you have a
skill set still apply and then get in
get your foot in the door and talk to
somebody and if you get a rejection from
an interview write them back and do say
something like I understand why you
rejected me but I think you might want
to reconsider because I can do this and
if you show that that initiative that
drive that motivation a lot of companies
will will take a second chance and look
at you from that perspective but the
other thing is I would encourage people
to also go out and start distinguishing
themselves from others you know because
like my coding boot camp we had you know
20 people in my class 21 people in my
class 21 people out interviewing for
jobs we all have the exact same skills
we went through the same three-month
training camp the people that were
writing articles or doing things above
and beyond that and they could put that
on their resume we're the first people
to get hired out of that coding boot
camp so it's your future it's your
career you can take control of it and be
able to do something on the side like
that where you know the like the
live-streaming you know I'm learning how
to program I make mistakes do live
stringing people will reach out to you
write an article about something people
will reach out to you I've I've had
people that have come up to me and
meetings and I mean at conferences and
just say I just want to shake your hand
I follow you on twitter I read your
stuff and I'm like I don't know who
these people are but they know who I am
what I've done so then those are the
recommendations that I would give to
people that's that's some great advice
Jennifer about 15% of the people in the
free code camp community the use free
code camps learning platform and are
transitioning into developer jobs our 45
and older here's someone who in her 50s
did learn an entirely new additional
skill set
granted you already knew Lotus Notes
programming and things like that but I
imagine you had to learn a lot of new
stuff too yep
what would be some advice for people who
are in their 40s 50 60s who are planning
to transition who may feel discouraged
by the you know the perception in many
cases that it's harder for people to get
into tech if they're doing it as a
second or third career that's that's a
very good question because I did a
tendon cutting boot camp when I was 51 I
actually turned 52 in the middle of that
three-month coding boot camp I would
encourage everybody to do it you're
never too old to start to learn to get
into tag and a lot of people that are
older or discouraged because they're
like I'm too old that you know I don't
know this and I'm but here's my take on
that for somebody that's older you've
got decades of life experiences business
experiences that people in their 20s or
30s aren't going to have for 20 or 30
years now and even if you are learning
to program you're going to have business
experience that you can apply to any
project that you're working on in a
company and that is invaluable to any
company to have because if you're
thinking about coming out with the new
product or a new app or something like
that you're going to be able to provide
input and direction because of that
experience that nobody else has and then
because of that you're going to end up
producing a better product a better
quality AB
you know something like that and it's
just become better because of that
experience that you're going to be able
to offer up to potential employers what
are some first steps you would say if
somebody is on the fence about whether
they should take the jump and pursue
coding let's say hypothetically they are
somebody who's worked in a completely
unrelated field like doing accounting or
business management or they've been
somewhat technical like doing some IT
related stuff they want to get more
technical what would be the first few
things that you would recommend they
look into doing it the first thing I
would recommend them doing is to learn
the basics of HTML and CSS go out and
take a website that you like out there
and see if you can reproduce it in an
HTML and CSS yourself that will tell you
pretty much up front whether or not you
like programming and it's because some
people decide that I want to go into
tech and then once they get into it
they're like I hate it and that's fine
that's not it's not for everybody but
that's always a good way to start to
learn on there and but then also realize
that that programming isn't the only job
that somebody can have to get into tech
you can be a project manager you can be
a project owner you can be a quality
analyst you could be a front-end
developer you could be a back-end
developer you could do machine language
AI you could be a scrum master there are
a wide range of skills that are out
there but I would recommend that
everybody start off with something basic
like HTML and CSS which is just
solidified that you enjoyed this
experience before you go jump into it
you know from the deep end because then
if you don't like it you've saved
yourself from that and if you do like it
then you're motivated to Jacek Allah
keep learning from the
point Thank You Jennifer and I'm curious
you've made this transition over the
past few years you've created an
incredible corpus of job application of
like interviewing prep material video
articles what are some of your ambitions
for the next year or so a friend and I
are gonna be starting a podcast we're
going to be talking about getting more
women into tech which i think is a very
valuable thing that we need to do and
we're also going to be creating a whole
series of videos that we talked about
the different roles in tech how to get
into tech how to finance your career
going into tech and stuff like that but
that's the one thing that I'm going to
be working on but the other thing that
was I mentioned earlier and my
introduction is go out and tell people
about how to get into open source
software how to contribute to open
source software people think it's gonna
be too technical it's going to be too
much and with what I'm doing right now
with you know the nodejs with their
mentorship program I can be able to
create videos and show what I've done
and be able to look at people can look
at that and to say oh I could possibly
do that too and then I can show them how
they can get involved with that because
if you have something like that you've
contributed open source on your resume
when you're getting your first job it's
one of those things that makes you stand
out from the crowd and will make you get
it to get a job a lot quicker but I want
to keep contributing and giving back to
the community and I'm excited you know
for what's coming up Jennifer I can tell
you that you're gonna have at least one
listener for your podcast day one I am
very excited to hear it and
I frequently encourage everybody to
start a podcast because it's one of
those things where people have so much
time they're driving they're going for a
walk that they can fill with these
wonderful podcasts and we need more
podcasts on women and tech especially
there are a few really good ones that I
listen to but it's it's just a
underexplored under publicized
issue an area where we can make a big
difference so I'm very excited about the
upcoming podcast especially all right
thank you so much Jennifer I'm gonna
bring up your information again
everybody be sure to check out Jennifer
on Twitter she is constantly creating
really exciting stuff Jennifer bland
rat-race grad what a great for handle
thank you again Jennifer
[Music]
hey yeah okay thanks for coming yeah I
just interviewed Jennifer if you haven't
met her she's somebody you definitely
need okay I'll see you love it
all right in the Egg Chair we have none
other than the legendary absolutely
legendary Stuart Taylor I'm sorry I'm
gonna take Nicole difficulty here
did you plug in that URL again I'm I'm
using I'm using Firefox what is it
called
it's like a Firefox browser that's like
completely privacy focused so it doesn't
have any history or anything like that
and it doesn't allow any ads or any
trackers or anything it's really cool
but I accidently hit back hidden because
there's no history I couldn't get back
to the the web app that Matt built a
perfect no this is great
you look great man thank you thank you
so much for flying out from Bali castle
which is town in Ireland right by
Belfast reasonably close to Belfast
right so oh it refreshed so I can find
you alphabetically I got it I got it
so Stewart and I go way back
he's been a prolific contributor to free
code camp
[Music]
my change didn't stick so I guess we've
discovered a bug in this app whenever
you manually enter a name if you refresh
the app the name system seems to
disappear I inputted it initially you
just read and put everything real quick
and then we'll pop it up on the we're
doing some live debugging here it's
really cool it's really intuitive I
think that like having a search field
where I can just type a name in it
autocompletes would be helpful so I'm
not having to scroll through 250 names
of top contributors but yeah overall my
hats off to you
Matt for for making this amazing app and
thanks also for grabbing people and
bringing them over here so I could talk
to him it yeah he's doing he's doing the
piece and the thumbs up Terminator 2
style okay mr. Stuart Taylor coming to
us from Bali Castle Stewart doesn't need
an introduction but I'm gonna give him
one just in case you haven't heard of
this miraculous human being Stuart was
you know and I okay so Stuart has been a
prolific contributor to free code camp
if you've used the freako camp
curriculum in the past two months it's
running on the learn application that
Stuart led the creation of Stuart has re
are connected for eco camps learning
platform completely to be a static
application and to interact with an API
and it's extremely fast it's all react
it's a single page app it'll lazy load
challenges if they haven't already been
loaded when you're using it but as a
result it's faster than ever it's
smoother than
Stewart also created the freako camp
guide which is an incredibly important
part of freako camp
it's a lay person accessible version of
like the Mozilla developer Network would
be a good way to describe it and we have
4,000 plus articles there on all range
of topics
you know C++ sequel of course JavaScript
and and little articles on pretty much
every single challenge on the free
cocaine curriculum many Witcher stubs
and we welcome your help
flushing those stubs out so that people
can have like kind of a corresponding
hint with spoilers and things like that
in case they get stuck kind of challenge
but Stewart has been building all these
things he's been doing so much exciting
stuff to to help us like simplify the
DevOps flow improve site reliability you
name it that's Stewart and his recent
contributions to free code camp Stewart
now works full time for free code camp
he is the senior-most developer on our
team at this point he touches pretty
much every aspect of free code camp
he even has production access to the
database in case he wants to pull a get
lab and wipeout of days where the data
I'm just I'm just kidding if you have an
or forget lab work we love that you're
post-mortal on that get lab friends so
I've been talking a lot about Stewart
I'm gonna let Stewart tell you a little
bit about his background and how he came
to be a developer alright hi how you
doing
so I say my working life started out I
was was in the military in there for
eight years once I'm finished I
I saw work for a telecoms company
building fiber-optic network so I built
the internet around where I live it's
only a small country of 1.8 million
people I have one fast internet and I
won't have being a stay-at-home dad and
in that time I thought well my wife she
had a business and she needed a website
so we went to Squarespace and
just used their website builder a bit or
website it's fantastic worked great
until we decided to change the header
image on the front page now originally
there was a picture of a woman my wife
doesn't an aesthetics business so the
original image was a woman on the left
hand side and we had the business name
and a call to action but on the right
hand side well we got some new images
and the image people wanted on their
head air was the one was on the right
hand side we didn't want the title and
the call-to-action button over her face
we want to move across the other side so
I rang Square Spanish said hey how can I
get the site title and this little
button over to the other side of the
page and the person on the phone said
that you can't do it with it it's not
possible
so I thought that doesn't sound quite
right so I went on the internet around
and I thought well how can I move a
button to this side of a page on a
website and found a little stuck over
low thing and typed in some CSS didn't
know what that was tightening a word but
alright that was pretty cool I don't
know what else I can do what can I get
this so if you scroll down the page is
another image that comes in is what can
I get that to slide in you know like all
the other cool websites out there no
clue how to do it so how do I make an
image slide in from the side of the page
and a website Stack Overflow something
about jQuery copy and paste this code
all right worked brilliant wonder what
else I can do so I went searching around
and found some courses on like coke Adam
II and all that and work through a few
of them didn't quite like too much of it
somehow found free coke am I started
working through their curricula yeah
this works for me and this is really
easily HTML so if I have seen this
before I'll bash that out
brilliant right JavaScript is that like
jQuery I don't know but carry on going
and it's all got to the point where I
was comfortable with what I was doing
and I thought was this this freako camp
they give back to the community as a
whole is wondering how can I make I
cannot
how can I help them that's where I found
github and when looking through all the
issues and I found an issue where there
was a diagram of it was describing some
sort of class name on a bootstrap button
and there was a typo on the image and
the issue was to change the image so the
would have been better if it was just
code if you just have a button on the
screen and have
the snippet of what that code is for the
button and I managed to get that
implemented and after a bit of - in
frame we've got a pull request opened
and I got it merged and it was the
greatest feeling in the world
somebody sort of verified my ability to
code something you know so like somebody
Haddix said like yeah this is good
enough for free code camp and it was
accepted
there's pushed live and it was just
amazing all right well what else can I
do and that sort of pattern went on from
what else can I do how do we do that
right that's how I've managed to do it
all right
somebody said it's good enough so what
else could sort of snowball effectively
to where I was implementing features in
react I mean six months before that was
happening know what react was I was
getting featured implemented and I was
fixing bugs and it turns out then that
somebody wanted to hire me to do it
something I was doing for a hobby and of
course I said yeah all right and then
Here I am today
knocking code out all over the place
extending the reach of freako camp
making it easier for people to get there
and start learning the way I did
so Stewart you have learned so much just
in the past two or two-and-a-half years
since you really dug in just that
Squarespace incident as that was day one
for you really
with this new career and now you know we
talked to developer all the time we were
talking to some some people working as
full-time devs last night at a major
company and you were basically schooling
them on the the trade offs of
implementing graph QL and and why graph
QL was in many cases superior to just a
like hacking together a REST API that
has similar functionality so what does
that journey been like on an emotional
level
going from being a fiberoptic engineer
from being a veteran in the British Air
Force with with tours in both
Afghanistan and Iraq I'll add to that
that transition into being on the edge
of the newest web development technology
and implementing it and implementing it
it's scale where millions of people are
using of each month what does that
process felt like for you
it's been emotional and tiring but
overall has been rewarding even just
noticing how I've progressed in tackling
issues and thinking through what needs
to be on what the aim of what it is I'm
doing how my roadmap to get to that goal
before it was just well showing a lot of
it was just googling how to do how to do
make the thing do the thing we'll do
that now but I don't know it's the all
sort of humbling is the reach you can
have just for fixing the smallest little
thing I mean it could be the simplest
like a little at week with some Styles
maybe or a little tweak with some HTML
it's maybe tiny for you and it's trivial
to implement but the effect it has like
you say on millions of people like so
there may be some maybe it's an
accessibility issue I mean myself has
been an able-bodied person or
able-minded ablevision I wouldn't see
the issue there but somebody's flight up
said if you did this it'd make it easier
for us to understand the concept or to
interact with the platform doing
something as trivial as just tweaking
some HTML CSS and having an impact on
potentially millions of people it's
humbling
and you get wholesome knowing that
everything that every feature you
implement or bug you fix it's helping
other people learn to do what you were
doing which is the end of this that's
the goal of freako campus to get people
programming I'd do it again right on 3rd
well thanks for sharing your thoughts on
that the emotional journey where you are
today we are extremely grateful to have
you on our team I'm learning so much
from you we're getting so much done
things are moving so quickly free
cooking now the big big part of it is
having you leaving a lot of these new
services and rolling things out and
helping us rapidly we architected the
Stewart I'm gonna go ahead and pop up
Stewart's Twitter information uh I
strongly recommend following him I think
he's a it's a very interesting guy who
tweets some interesting stuff and just
keep an eye out for new projects in the
pipeline coming from Stewart because
they are very exciting anything else any
last words for the audience to keep on
honking well well put thanks sir
great so we're gonna do some pretty
quick ones I'd like to talk
okay cool see you then hey have a seat
bill you get to sit in the egg chair men
in black chair I don't know anything
about this thing so bill doesn't need
much of an introduction if you've read
the free cooking at medium publication
you've almost certainly seen him on
there he is prolific he's done quite a
few podcast episodes as well and he's
just an extremely experienced
knowledgeable developer can work coding
for more than 20 years done high-profile
projects for lots of different
corporations and government agencies
around Canada bill welcome thank you so
much and no pressure that's the heck of
an introduction
thanks Quincey well you're somebody whom
I look up to as a mentor I've learned so
many software engineering best practices
from you what are some areas of software
engineering that you would say are the
most interesting for you that you really
want to drill down and continue to
specialize and as your career progresses
so one of the things that I come across
a lot is the notion so just for
background for the sake of background
and sorry I'm going to talk for a second
nothing hey I never have a problem talk
so what I do is I'm a freelance
consultant and so oftentimes I airdrop
into an organization when most of their
apps are like seven to ten two more
years old and they've got so much
technical debt that the the engineering
team the dev team is spending most of
their time you know dealing with that
technical debt like eighty ninety
percent of the resources are being spent
on that and the business side of the
house or the clients in the in there are
really frustrated because they can't get
much value out of this dev team so
they're paying all this money for all
these engineers and they're not really
getting much out of it because the
engineers are really busy you know
living with the hell that they've
created for themselves
and there are some really common things
that I see from client to find the
client that contribute to that around
how how those apps were were built in
the first place and and how they were
you know basically it's a problem of
architecture and so that's an area that
I'm you know as I get more and more
experienced I think that's a really key
vital thing and I don't think that you
know I don't know that that that's the
first thing you're gonna learn is
appropriate your come in a free code
camp and you know you haven't written a
lick of JavaScript that's probably not
the first thing you should focus on but
as as people come into organizations and
and they're you know getting their first
first job or they're in their first year
these are the kinds of things that I
want to figure out how to help people
learn and understand and so it really
comes down to like how how you architect
your application and and the common one
of the most common things is the the
tight coupling of business logic
integration logic and third-party
dependencies so you've got some
framework that's like you know some
framework or library that's like the the
hot thing of the of the moment and then
you've got some some integration of your
dependencies and you've got all your
business logic and it's one kind of ball
of mud that's all really tightly coupled
together so I see that over and over and
over and over and over again and then
what happens is you know fast forward
several years that whatever framework or
library it was is like no longer the
hotness and in fact it's virtually
abandoned and full of security holes the
business logic that you have in there is
not well documented no one understands
it no one knows what to do with it and
nobody wants to touch the thing because
they're like well if we touch this we
break like the universe and so we don't
know what to do and so so trying to
teach people how to tackle and solve
those problems is what I'm becoming more
and more interested in and I have it I
think a few ways into it but I still
haven't liked
fully wrap my mind around it sorry
that's like a super long detail thanks
for - yeah and you have a newsletter dev
mastery that often delves into a lot of
these more advanced I would take
considerations and architecture
decisions and and how to prevent the
kind of toxic technical debt as opposed
to the more manageable thank you for
that right yeah I mean you're never
gonna be like debt free or technical
debt free but if you you know if you
think about an organization if you kind
of zoom out and think about like okay
they're pouring money they're investing
money into like their dev team and less
and less of that money is going to like
generating new value because it's all
being spent on like dealing with the
craft of the past that that's a bad
scenario right so yeah so I put this
newsletter and that you can get from dev
mastery com that I send out as often as
I can when I have time and these are
some of the types of things that I like
to tackle so that and then you know just
articles that I find interesting topics
that I find interesting that I think
would be will be helpful to others at
pretty much at all levels I think but
you really people in the first the
feedback that I get is people in the
first sort of five years of their career
from like zero to five years tends to be
sort of the sweet spot for the stuff
that I put out you know again if it's
like if you've written your first line
of code yesterday it might not be for
you yet but soon it'll be for you soon
and then you know if you just got your
first job for sure I'm gonna hit you
with stuff that you you need to start
thinking about and so yeah so that's
been
awesome so you've done so much for the
free cocaine community and for the
developer community at large by singing
your best practices and we're very
excited about you continuing to create
more tools and resources for people to
learn to code and especially learn
advanced computer science and advanced
you know application design what are
what are some of the things that you're
interested in in covering in the near
future so test-driven development is is
an area that I'd really like to get into
and specifically test-driven development
with JavaScript because I think there's
lots of content for TDD for a lot of
other languages but I haven't seen
anything yet that really nails it for
JavaScript and that then that's complete
enough so I'd like to I'd like to write
more about that and definitely like
through the roof read code yeah through
free code campus and as a medium for
that or as a channel for that I think it
would be a great Avenue and so that's
that's probably what's next on the
horizon if we're kind of asking you on
the spot but would you be open to me
interviewing you on our podcast at some
point of course yeah yeah for sure for
you Quincy anything come on I mean I
came to New York I'm at a party you give
me free food for sure alright great well
we really appreciate you flying down
from Ottawa where the that's the capital
of Canada yes so hence like the
government contracts and things like
that okay great well thanks so much for
coming down I know it was this is a
decent flight like how long did it take
you to fly down it's actually really
fast it's 90 minutes so I didn't suffer
too badly but yeah it's a fast flight
yeah well thank you so much for coming
down and we're gonna be seeing a lot
more of Bill on the YouTube channel on
the podcast on the medium publication at
some point I know you know a lot about
design patterns
and advanced topics like TDD if you'd be
interested in helping create some some
guides and some introductions and
primers we would share that with the
entire world because these are things
that people need to know that aside from
like dusting off the Gang of Four book
but there need to be some more
accessible entrees into these these
topics and I think that you're the kind
of seasoned practitioner who also is
good at articulating things and
expressing things in a way that a
relative lay person can control of to
put your talents to more use within the
community yeah I would love to
contribute more I'm in you know I work
as a freelance consultant and like every
freelancer I have the dilemma of I'm
always worried about where my next job
is gonna come so I always have too many
jobs but but absolutely I would love to
do more and I'd be happy to
and yeah the podcast anytime you want
Quincy I'm I'm all-in and as soon as I
have content around some of those topics
I'll definitely look to you to help me
publish them so thanks well bill some
thank you so much for coming out here
everybody who's watching this bill surd
on Twitter and check out dev mastery
Cheers thank you
trap Hey just a few more minutes I guess
we supposed to go here so I'm gonna even
I'm fine you know talk to this gentleman
let's do it and I'm gonna try to keep
these like five ish minutes just a good
idea yeah I'd love to talk to Joe have a
seat Rafael is it's great to see you
again man I saw I saw you in April last
time I came in New York City hung out
with you at eBay's headquarters I think
yes yeah welcome hi I guess you're are
you from Brooklyn specifically no I live
in the Bronx the Bronx I always get the
to be boroughs mixed up thank you so
much for coming out tonight
so Raphael has been a major contributor
to the free cocaine wiki which was a
precursor to the free coke camp guide if
you had a guide that freakin better work
there's a good chance that some of the
articles you'll read there were authored
by none other than Raphael originally
Raphael tell us a little bit about
yourself well I am really from the
Dominican Republic can here 2005 looking
for software engineer career but my
translations were in that used so I went
for computer science which was closest
and from there I finished school I start
applying for jobs you know a lot of
emails interviews ain't nothing
happening so I decide
I will go and study something else and I
started doing let me check Python or
some programming language C there were a
lot of jobs looking for those skills and
checking different languages signing up
with JavaScript and I said this is my
language I can use in the front end
occasion the back end since like if I
learned this I'll be good
anywhere I go so I started studying that
I discovered free cocaine by say boot
camp seems to be where everybody is
doing to learn fast get a job and this
is what I need mind you at the time my
song was very good like three so I still
even my family I have a kid I finished
school and trying to get a job soon aim
free cook what's the place I said I'm
gonna do these this looks promising I'm
gonna do it and I started working on the
challenges and because I have bad memory
I don't trust my own memory I said let
me take notes but let me take good notes
not like I did back in high school right
so you essentially took your notes on
all the challenges and that formed the
basis of the wiki and I remember
approaching you two years ago two and a
half years ago and you had these
elaborate notes with your solutions and
everything on all these free coke game
channel challenges and we use that as
the basis for the wiki so what have you
been up to I guess last time we hung out
was April 2017 we hung out what have you
been up to since then most of the
working I started my job May 1st
so I congratulations thank you actually
what's main last year so now I've been
there for over a year
I've been focusing on that it is not wet
development per se but I decided to take
a chance and not just focus this is what
I study I only want to work on this so I
went more into business size in working
with AI but I still like the I was
grateful stacking I'm planning on
consuming the new curriculum I add too
so recently and say oh this is great I
should do this well if you do it we
would very much welcome your detailed
notes a lot of those challenges don't
yet we we added more than a thousand new
challenges to the curriculum and a lot
of them don't have detailed notes yet
yeah slow and there are a lot of thing I
check I have delete legacy front end
certificate I never finished the back
end because I wanted to master we at
least get to a good level before a
principal on the full stack so I'm
definitely looking forward to the riad
articles now having had a chance to give
your son he's like five or six now how
old is he right now he's eight oh he's
eight okay so as he turned any coding
yet are you thinking about getting him
in front of a computer a little bit
actually he has he asked me to teach him
how to code he's a little familiar we
freq okay because he will always see me
in freako cam and I tried teaching him
and it turns out he was more interested
about our code and basically the bigger
gains that they had to getting
interested yeah yeah those games are
great for kids and it's so is he doing
scratch yeah he was doing scratch and I
tried to happen stick to it and he
wanted to go more towards just a full
game where he would use play so you know
it takes a little but at least the
interest is there right well freako game
is designed for adults primarily and not
kids so that's not terribly surprising
but I'm impressed that he's coating
already at age 8 I think that's great
yeah I mean right now he's more into art
but the interest is there so I'm
planning or nurturing aid whether he's
planning going for actual development or
just getting some Coe skills so he can
eventually have his own website for his
comics which he likes to do
well Raphael thank you so much for your
many contributions as a free cocaine
community I see you're wearing a free
coaching of shirt this is the Halloween
shirt from last year with the CSS ghost
shirt right here yeah you're the ghost
hey man
it's been real stick around I'm excited
to catch up and hear how things are
going thanks again Raphael Jojo come on
over here man
all right just look yeah it takes a
little getting used to doesn't it I
couldn't find a chair that was a little
or I mean this is like this is a cool
visual chair all right
I'm pulling you up on here Joe vintage
Joe Hill on Twitter check out Joe so Joe
hails from Norfolk Virginia where he has
been leading the free coconut study
group yes tell us a little bit about
that well I think it was 2015 when you
originally made the call when I first
found them free code camp it was
probably in I think he put out the call
in like October or November of 2015 I
was when I found free count game it was
like July of 2015 and I was I was broke
I was a has been a Salesman for a
start-up and I lost my job doing that
and I wasn't making very good money of
that anyway so I was a janitor at night
and so I had had it being broke I was
making about $800 a month at that point
and I just had said I really want to
learn how to code I'm tired of I'm tired
of just kind of all my programming
friends were traveling and they're
having good lives and their social media
feeds made them look very happy and I
was not so one so one night you know
everybody told me I needed to learn
JavaScript so I typed in cheap
JavaScript resource or cheap JavaScript
coding camp or something like that
because all the boot camps at the time
were costing 10 15 grand and
and I didn't have that and I found
freako camp and so it was about 2:00 in
the morning as as my want because I
don't sleep very much and I said oh it's
how I learned HTML in a night and I said
there's something to this and I became
really passionate about it because I was
learning something for free I I realized
I was on a path that was gonna do well
and all I had to do was put it into time
I didn't have the brainpower but kind of
like lifting weights or doing anything
else you just got to put in the time you
gotta put in the work and so when the
call came out for the you for us to
start up like a local meetup I was at
guess we need to do this and there was
one already in for Ginny B towards the
city right next to Norfolk but nobody
was going to it and I said well I have a
lot of coding friends I can ask them to
be speakers I'm sure they would want to
contribute open-source was kind of a new
idea to me
didn't quite know what it was it's like
so how do you make money on this how do
you how do you make a living at doing
this and what I didn't realize is that
as you build a community as you build a
reputation and as you help others that
that follows that follow suit so this
was my way of a newbie coder not knowing
how to teach still contributing and
giving people who are just like me
content that was going to be good and
useful for them if they wanted to
continue down that path so that's pretty
I've been doing it ever since I think
I've become a lot more passionate about
the code as well I couldn't have done
any I wouldn't be sitting here if it
wasn't for like John small who was a guy
who I threw one of my contacts helped
get him an internship as he came out of
a boot camp and he jokes he's like I
don't know if the word blood oath is
applicable here but he goes that's why I
feel like and he's a very good
programmer and he's paired program with
me he's taught me a lot and then he just
kept coming to the meetups as well and
he's become kind of like a de-facto
admin there
arranging like meetups at nights that I
can't make it
helping with algorithm teaching things
that I'm still not great at but he is
he's excellent and I'm really thankful
that there's a part of the community
that's just as passionate about teaching
as I am so so yeah we've been doing that
for almost four years now
whether it be in virtual or and we're in
the real trying to teach different
topics but the same time still trying to
help people as they continue
undercoating journey and focusing on the
freako camp the curriculum has been kind
of our focus or 2018 and that's really
been helping ya know what do you all
think of the new curriculum I feel like
I'm behind I got my I got my friend and
certification in 2016 and I got my first
gig coding in 2017 so I've been learning
a lot of stuff in between it like I was
learning iOS development for a long time
and every time I went back I felt like I
was falling behind and I think seeing
that d3 curriculum come out now the node
curriculum be more robust seeing react
every time I'm clicking on an arrow and
I'm seeing classes scroll down I think
that's that makes me really happy
because they from where it was when when
we started out to where it is now it's
just so much of a difference you can
easily get lost in like articles and and
videos and those are all really helpful
I think it's the navigating of it is the
tough bit and I think that's where the
community really helps in and say don't
focus on this don't focus on it focus on
this and you can build up to that and I
think that's that's been the fun part on
the topic of just focusing on learning
fundamentals and and you are doing a job
that's very different from what you
originally prepared for so talk a little
bit about your transition from web
development to mobile development to
sequel focus development yeah absolutely
so I so my my my current job is as a
sequel and T Seagle transact sequel
developer and that's dealing with data
within a financial framework I had no
idea what I was doing with databases how
to
information and put it into a database I
didn't know how to do any of that I had
a front-end certification and from there
I was like I like iOS development I'm
gonna focus on that and I focus on that
for about a year learning Swift and I
really wanted to do it and I was very
passionate about it I was buying a lot
of books I had invested a lot of money
and time into it and then I get a call
from a recruiter saying hey we want you
to be a programmer with us we work with
databases mainly and with data so that
would that's going to be your job and
writing scripts for it and I was like
okay and when I first got it I said well
I don't know if I really want to do this
I want to keep focusing on mobile but
the more I started messing with the data
is are you writing Python scripts and
PowerShell scripts too
you
okay areas go on yes sorry about the
camera thing but yeah I think what I've
been learning was that as you learned if
you're just starting out or if you're
halfway through and you're not sure how
that job is going to how that how all
this is going to work out into a job
it's going to work out and a job thank
you thank you Quincy's sit-in that's
very nice of you but like I said if you
don't know how that's gonna work out
within a job or if you don't know if you
end up in a situation where you're
getting paid to be a programmer just go
with it
don't don't stress that it's not what
you've been learning don't don't feel
like it's been a waste of time because
it really has it and and I've said this
to you before but my life has been a
lilypad of jobs - jobs - jobs - jobs and
that's through background or education
or whatever just circumstances and a lot
of them haven't been the greatest but
the universe god whatever I think the
universe but we'll just throw these
circumstances at you and you just gotta
you just got to kind of go with it and
in your coding journey no matter what
just try to look for the positive things
look for the things that you like to do
try to work on those by a udemy course
for 10 bucks to explore it more if it's
there's no free resources do something
like that and you're not gonna waste a
ton of money and you won't be
disappointed I don't think so well
thanks so much for sharing your
background you're very non-conventional
background your triumph of going from
janitor to sequel developer and
you know a day-to-day applying all these
concepts and skills that you've built up
over the past years and I just want to
thank you again for your stewardship
with a Norfolk group and everything
you're doing to bring more people to
coding and helping them accelerate their
own careers and transition into new new
careers I really want to be as involved
as I can with free coke half I'm super
passionate about it I'm passionate about
technology and the life that it can give
people and I want to thank you for
founding the group of just founding the
website itself and all the work that
everybody's put into it as a community I
think that's really important so thanks
again thank you so much Jo so Jo's
information is up on the screen vintage
Jo he'll follow him on Twitter this guy
is exceptionally interesting and just
while you're here this tattoo is so
eye-catching it's so amazing
very very well done like my compliments
to the artist thanks Joe
alright Victoria do you wanna hop on
[Music]
maybe maybe we could do something
different
Victoria Mike would you like to
interview one another I mean you're so
you know each other so well over the
years I want to watch Mike Mike is such
an interesting guy he's probably got a
lot of good questions too so Victoria
has been interacting with the chat and
there's somebody very special in the in
the chat whom we'd like to recognize
Murph we wish you were here glad to see
you actor interacting on the channel and
Quincy did say hi hi Quincy hey so I'm
here with Victoria I'm gonna pull her up
so you can follow her on Twitter she's
on Twitter nia skywalk that's a cool
name
alright and as a matter of fact I do
have Nia's skywalk great so this is
Victoria Carey Olek alright
Carrie Olek and she is actually the
woman who created the free coke camp NYC
Facebook group back in the day there was
a day when there was not a New York City
group like one of the most popular
cities in the world
right so Victoria thank you so much for
joining us here tell us a little bit
about your history with free coke
Cameron
well when I initially fit went into free
code camp I was looking for JavaScript
help
I had just left the job I was doing
freelancing and while everybody was ok
with html/css they wanted to have
JavaScript and while I was familiar with
copy/paste use I want to know how it
worked and found free code camp and
started doing the challenges one of the
challenges that popped up was hey if
there's not a FB group and free code and
for free code game why'd you make it I'm
like okay let's check then we had a
group because I created that as for as
people started joining they were saying
let's all meet up let's all meet up I'm
like ok where it's good we had a couple
people who have recently moved or had
recently moved at that time wanted to
meet up but nobody actually wanted to
make the meetup so what ended up
happening was I eventually got a couple
of volunteers to come together to be
leaders and we put together an idea for
a coffee in code which we had run across
on the free code camp group that Quincy
was running at the time was still
running hadn't even sure I'm sorry but
we great thing copying code being agree
make it a short thing meet everybody we
put that together and at each of those
meetings it kind of grew and grew and
grew and we ended up meeting some people
like Megan like Michael you probably see
later who ended up becoming our new
leaders and have been holding the fort
together for the last three years
basically every so often we could get
together and try to do something else
like I tried to have a leader summit but
then then that kind of fell through
so I'd like to actually get more leaders
at some point so if you're out there and
you want to do something in New York
City talk to me you got my information
come talk to me because I want you to be
a leader so that we can have one group
day studying every day of the week as
long as we can okay come on in New York
City is such a huge city there are so
many people here are so many
neighborhoods so many boroughs how many
different groups do you say are active
right now to your knowledge within the
New York City metropolitan area I've
every time I find one I put it into our
introduction our kind of description on
New York City I think there was about 10
at last count in the metropolitan area
including Bronx and Brooklyn and New
Jersey City and even something out in
Old Bridge New Jersey so if you're
watching from Old Bridge high that's
pretty far out for and I have that
listed on there yeah and I understand
that you and Mike I'm working here for a
moment
have been considering potentially like
we need better tooling around these
study groups than just relying on
Facebook groups and and what have been
some of your thoughts for what could
make it easier for people to discover
free coke amp groups and to hear about
them and to come to them so what my idea
has been is to create something very
similar to a meetup group but just for
coders and have it at a website that is
very prominently free code camp New York
City and invite people who code to come
in whether they know what free code camp
is or not at the time so that they can
the
discover our wonderful group and
continue their growth the idea was to
have something that will allow us to not
only have short once once one meeting
events but also multiple events over
time and maybe repeating events and then
also huge events where people can
discuss things very similar to how
meetup group works but different in that
it's a little bit more facebooking
that's the idea eventually we're going
to get that going yeah well we're
interested in building something like
that
we love Meetup it's a great tool but
it's like 15 20 bucks a month for a city
group and when you have thousands of
groups it doesn't really scale for a
small nonprofit like so we're I'm very
interested in getting kind of a feature
set and ideas and doing some user
testing with you as a starter group
leader who's put a lot of thought into
this and I understand that as far as
like advancing the web presence of free
coke of New York City you've actually
bought a few domains - yes I bought a
couple domains of free coke app NYC calm
because I want people to not be on
Facebook all the time and you'd still be
able to access the same stuff that we
have on Facebook for you as well because
I know some people don't like Facebook
and sometimes Facebook hides posts so we
don't see what they are so I want you to
be able to find all the same resources
specifically for New York City folk I
mean we have a ton of resources on free
code camp as it is but not very much
like within the same same city a small
community great well we turn on your we
turn on your efforts to to create it
like a unique web presence just for a
frico camp New York City and I'm hopeful
that we can be linking to that and if
you want to have like a slack chat or if
you want to have a discord server
anything like that if you want to have
your own
discourse server like your own forum
we're gonna try to make it to where you
you know each study group can link to
all these different places where the
community congregates and have like they
can just have that wherever they want
and have their own web presence because
we're huge believers in the open web
everybody should have some territory of
their own on the on the open web not
just on these massive platforms so
Victoria I
I put your Twitter information back up
on there everybody who's who's here
infrequent in New York City check her
out she's kind of the the kingpin of
free cookie of New York if you will
thank you so much Victoria it's hard to
get out of this chair alright and one
more free cocaine New York person whom I
think everybody should get to know Mike
Mike Simcoe I'm gonna pull you up here
as well so Mike you like the shirt I
I feel very embarrassed because like I
didn't think about how how much higher
this was I'm actually not that tall over
person I'm like 511 but many of the
people I'm talking to are taller than me
but they look to her because of my
choice of chairs
sorry Mike tell us a little bit about
your experience venturing into software
development so far oh wow software
development well the the thing is that I
sort of was a passion since childhood
part of it anyway not web development
but software development in programming
is so I I've kind of cheated I didn't
start from Ground Zero
I started at probably when I was like 12
writing C++ code and tinkering around
with that I had no idea that was gonna
bring me anywhere in life that was
literally just a hobby people play with
trains I play with programs then wave
after many years later I was sitting in
New York after traveling a while and I
didn't have a job I didn't have anything
to do and
I was just I randomly stumbled upon a
meetup group which was run by Victoria
for freako camp and I found the
curriculum and I really liked how it was
structured just like one two three four
me web developer whatever because I
couldn't find before this website I
really could not find any concise
resources I mean there was stuff you
know called kademan whatever there was
things that are available but they were
kind of disjoin it or they were in the
form of just like here's a tutorial and
then you're done
here it was like 1 2 3 nonprofit
projects all of that and it felt like I
felt like exactly what I was looking for
but I could find before so started going
to program I realized I had a passion
for teaching at that point which I
didn't know before because just helping
out explaining complex subjects I guess
I have got a knack for it just
explaining things even little things
like for loops and while loops and
enclosures you know whatever
higher-order functions and somehow I'm
able to explain it to people in the way
they don't they'll understand and
another thing which is kind of weird the
best kept secret is if you want to learn
something better teach it to somebody
else right like you do and I never knew
that until I joined the group and I met
awesome people at this group I met
Victoria I met some of my best friends
here and now now this is basically I'm
stuck with it ha ha ha let's see you
know I even transitioned into web
development of full-time freelance web
development that's what I do I don't
actually have a job I was going through
a program and I found that I it just
organically happened I learned enough
through the program where I was able to
start taking on clients of my own and
just one day I woke up and realized hey
I can do this so describe that moment
when you realize hey I can succeed as a
freelancer like was there some specific
I mean you woke up but was there some
specific sequence of events where your
confidence kind of kicked in
[Music]
well yes but that moment probably have
did not happen when I was until I was
like face-to-face with a client because
my kind of teaching mode kicked in
because I am a teacher first I was a
teacher first and a developer second and
when I put my first ad online I was
super nervous it was a completely lame
ad honestly it was not I'm a developer I
can build oh boo your website for you it
literally was a one line thing that said
that said web programmer fixing website
fixing broken websites that's what it
said
fixing website problems and I got a call
from from a lady who had a private
business and she she had a complaint
that her website looked crappy on mobile
it didn't work her in didn't didn't
didn't look well on mobile at all and I
was about halfway through you know I was
about in the middle of the free
co-champs thing that I did wasn't even
finished I was like oh yeah there's this
thing called bootstrap I could totally
help you out and that's what a
confidence happened because I realized
she was looking at me for solutions she
wasn't judging me she wasn't testing me
she wasn't like oh let me see what your
credentials are or whatever she was
looking to me for solutions and I had
and I was like I've done this I can do
this you know whatever and then after
that it just started up I realized that
clients are they're basically like
students because part of what you do is
you educate you educate you meet with
them because they tell you what they
think they want sorry
sorry about that you have to they they
tell you what they think they want and
it's your job to actually give them what
they need including the knowledge and
the things so it that's when it happened
for me it happened for me after a
face-to-face meeting not when I woke up
when I woke up I was like I got a try
and I didn't have confidence I had
I had lots of stage fright I was like I
don't know how I'm gonna meet this
person even when they contacted me and
said I want to meet you at this cafe at
this time I was nervous I was
overdressed I was doing all that crazy
crap that you do when you go in and then
I showed up and I was like tell me your
story right and she's talking and I'm
listening and I'm realizing I'm just I'm
just being a friend here at this point
I'm being a friend and I'm being an
advisor like what can I do to this
person what could I do for this person
and that's that's kind of when it hit me
it sounds like you've picked up so many
insights about freelancing over over the
years and I would encourage you to write
about it or create a video series this
is one of the most common questions I
get is how should I get in involved in
freelancing and I tell people check out
the freelancer show it's a podcast it's
pretty good buy a bunch of long-term
freelancers but what would be the single
like if you had a single thing that you
give as advice for people who want to
get into freelancing who've been working
through the free cocaine curriculum or
even just building projects on their own
for a while and really want to start
making some monies of freelancer what
would be your single best advice for
them
the single best advice for them well how
about this okay
you are the expert chances are your
client knows a lot less than you do
about what he's asking you to do this is
why he's hiring you so you are the
expert and in that role this is this is
a people position almost it's your job
to convince the client that you can do
what's best for them and I guess I want
to say like they say in a joke they are
more afraid of you than you are of them
so that's you don't need to be ashamed
you don't need to be afraid
whatever you think you don't know and we
all struggle with this all the time we
all struggle with the the so called the
impostor syndrome they know a lot less
and they're coming to you for advice and
your job is to give them that advice if
you're trying to get into freelancing
just do it just start now start small
don't don't worry about even if you put
an ad out there and the first person you
get is just not the kind of client you
would want I mean there are different
circumstances keep trying and just grab
that first so after that first one that
first assignment whether it's just do
this one page for I'm not gonna get I
want to name actual money figures but
here's just do this one page for not
very much money just do it this is when
you get your first kind of grasp of the
skills that you possess you realize what
you can do what you can do well so thank
you so much Mike I'm gonna encourage
everybody to check out do you have a
Twitter presence or anything
yeah sure but how would people track you
down if they wanted to learn more about
you or read more about your yeah I don't
that meaning that I know I know that
some people are you know don't like
Facebook or whatever I am currently on
Facebook that's the best way to reach me
all right right on well thank you so
much Mike for leading the group for
sharing your insights on freelancing and
I speak I think for most of the
community when I say we'd love to have
some more articles that lay out some of
your insights because it sounds like
you've been through a lot and you've
learned a lot from the process Thanks
yeah let's change it up can we can we
so I'd like to interview both of them
yeah yeah I'm gonna sit in this egg
chair for a change
Wow just sitting in here the sound is so
different it's like putting your head
under water yeah so I'm here with two
amazing people
Johnny Bissell and and my niece Gary
thank you so much gentlemen for flying
out from your respective cities first
tell us a little bit about yourself
Johnny hi everyone I'm Johnny Bissell I
was a c-sharp the vb.net developer for
seven years with a knowledge of SQL what
I found was I was working on web forms
and quite old technology and I really
wanted to learn new things like node and
MongoDB and one of the guys I was
working with recommended free code camp
so I thought yeah I'll give you a try
and that was about two and a bit years
ago and I'm still plodding along through
the massive course but don't let that
put you off it's very good
so the the goal is to upscale basically
with new technologies and get more
relevant today work and then along the
ride I've spent a lot of time on the
forum and the chat rooms helping out new
beginners which is also aided mine
learning process so it's been great and
the course is improved over the years
and I made lots of friends I encourage
people to network and pair program and
meet other developers because it's
difficult to motivate yourself doing
stuff just purely on ease on yourself so
yeah any more questions yeah first let's
hear from money SHhhh
thank you so much for joining us thank
you thanks for having me here my name is
Manish I am a grad student in you see
since the University of Cincinnati in
Ohio I did my engineering from India and
computer science and after that I
decided to get a higher higher degree in
computer science so I joined you see
since then it's been a good journey I've
started getting to getting into more
more into software development starting
with Java and then recently I came
across I decided to get into JavaScript
because what's more important for me is
to build something and it's the same
happening right in front of me that's
that's where JavaScript is more powerful
than Java because we don't need a lot of
things to set it up you can do it
immediately with JavaScript just open
your browser write your code and you're
done so that's how I got into JavaScript
and that's how I got into free code
because when I was learning JavaScript
there were just tutorials everywhere you
read read read and there's no coding
exercises or challenges
that's where free code can was helpful
because I saw there were a series of
code challenges your elearn you write
you see your code if it doesn't pass you
ask for help and that's how you learn
and I mean with free code camp for about
two years now two three years now it's
it's been a pretty good journey so far I
used to hang around in the help Charles
me and there was one more camper called
Steven James he's a legend in the chat
rooms so it was fun hanging around there
ya hope to continue more in this Thank
You Manish and and so those are you
watching both of these gentlemen are
tremendous contributors to the free
cooking of community China bizzle is one
of the most prominent people helping
people on the forum look the other day I
looked earlier I was like I wonder how
long Johnny spent on the forum and
discourse the the forum software you he
is which is great it's open source check
it out it said that Johnny Bissell had
spent the equivalent of five waking days
on the forum helping people five days of
his life that's not including sleeping
and everything that's like five days at
his computer making people's lives
easier by answering their many questions
and that that is so profound so Johnny
tell us a little bit about what drives
you to help so many people what would
you say is there any is there some
moment where somebody helped you or do
you just enjoy helping people what what
causes you to be such a super helpful
person I would say that that probably
comes from might have gone I realize
I've got the experience of coding so I
enjoy going up I think I think as well
he used to give brownie points with
faithful of helping I thought hey I can
get some brownie fuzzier and then I was
trying to keep the street going I got a
street going for about one hundred and
ninety four days or something
not easy than doing projects 494 days so
some of that was a bit of
procrastination lost as well there's
other people that I met through doing
that who I now speak to anima once a
warm a sis
again that motivated to see people
progressing through the course so yeah I
bet guess because I've got a certain
level of knowledge I want to share that
and and I think it is better to give
than to receive
as Quincy comes from a teaching
background as well and my parents come
from that background as well so I guess
that's where I get the inspiration from
ya know there's something to do so maybe
maybe when I'm working on a projects I
just want to break from that I'll dip in
at the forum dipping in the chat room to
see what's going on this case of
breaking off from focusing on the same
thing all the time as well that's
another reason for doing it so yeah and
money how are you you've been such a
prolific contributor to the codebase
what what is spurred you to to jump in
and help out so much when I started
learning when I had questions or when I
had doubts the only place I used to go
to a Stack Overflow and unfortunately
people in Stack Overflow are not very
helpful most of the time no not friendly
at all so you would feel hesitant to ask
questions which you normally could ask
freely in a chatroom or in a forum so
when I joined free code camp I saw that
there are chat rooms where people are
willing to help it's not just where it's
not they're not condescending or they're
not
they don't expect you to know everything
before you ask the question so it's okay
to not not know everything and ask no
one will scold you for it no one will
think bad for it so that's how I got
into freakout cam and then I saw the
codebase on github and you realized
there were a few aspects where I already
knew things stuff like regular
expressions or front-end framework like
react or angularjs where it was
previously ad so I identified things
where I could contribute and obviously
the more you write code in oh that works
in a real life production scenario the
more you learn so I thought that was a
good way of upping my skills even more
so that's how I started contributing to
it and the more you do it the more you
get attracted to it so it's it's always
a good challenge to learn and contribute
there's lots of people on the forums and
chat rooms who will suggest tools to you
they're just fantastic like - - a
fantastic online tool for debugging code
so there's that benefit as well okay
just people recommending tools and
things all the time another great reason
to get involved speaking of getting
involved both of you have been so
involved over the past few years and I
like to think of free cocaine but still
being very early days if you look at if
you look at free code camp and then if
you look at like Wikipedia diver work
wikipedia has been going for about 18
years now and freako camp is tracking
very closely the Wikipedia's trajectory
you know like in terms of total use
usage of the the web application and the
total number of articles and
contributors and things like that for
example Wikipedia has about a hundred
thousand total contributors and free
code camp as thousands so we're all in
the same order of magnitude basically
we're on the trajectory - - we'd like to
be Wikipedia for learning about
technology and
you gentlemen seem to be very long-term
thinking and you've got bright careers
ahead of you
what are some ways that you think you
might be able to contribute to the
developer community the RICO camp and
other resources going forward continue
to help people in the forum's maybe also
run the leads Meetup
so helping those guys getting through
the early stages the the very difficult
thing about an online course and courses
in general is keeping it up to date
there's always something you come in on
I'm bored so it's really important
everything stays relevant enough today
there's nothing worse than say when you
buy a book and it's already talking
about the old version of that code
anything well should I be learning
Python 2.7 when version 3.4 so I could
sure you'd appreciate the frustration of
people might write a load of challenges
and things already out of date how
frustrating that be so hopefully I can
help keep things up to date and keep
things relevant that's one of the
challenges
when you're great yeah I agree one more
thing I can think of is free code camp
has the guides recently in github it is
a wonderful resource just like Wikipedia
it's not just limited to react or our
front end there there are topics on a
whole lot of sections like Python Java
OS operating systems so what I could
what I think is if if we push to make
guides a more accessible and more in a
way that beginners who are new to free
code camp they contribute more to guides
that would help and what I've noticed is
that even in the main free code camp
repo there are sometimes issues with
newcomers trying to set up their
repositories and it's not working out in
the local environments so that maybe we
could contribute to that so that that in
turn has taught newcomers to get set up
fire far faster well thank you so much
for joining us you all have the
distinction of being our last interview
for the evening I yeah yeah go grab a
beer I'm gonna I'm gonna grab some soda
I don't drink beer but I may I don't
think maybe load up on some carbs over
here we've got all these sandwiches left
but thank you so much for coming out
we're gonna have Top Contributor parties
every year this one's going off to a
great start this is our first one ever
but we're gonna be in Dublin and in Hong
Kong if you can make it to the Dublin
one Johnny I'm not sure but I know it's
not as far from Leeds to Dublin as it is
from who leads to New York City but and
then we're doing Hong Kong too you know
you're welcome all you are all welcome
and all the talk intruder parties and
I'm hoping that some of the people
watching this right now will contribute
to the community and we'll make the list
of very elite capable people who are
helping drive this community forward and
helping set the course for so many
people who want to become developers and
who want to become more technical and
break in to break into tech so thank you
both gentlemen and thank you everybody
for
watching these interviews I think we're
gonna do quick closing can we do a quick
closing before we start cleaning up yeah
yeah yeah let's do that can you all
right thank you again hey bring it in
bring it in I want a hug funny scary all
right hey it works it's so crazy thank
you so much for helping me make it quiet
in here so I didn't get a chance to
interview everybody I think I was
interviewing people for like three hours
straight but I did get an interview a
ton of people in next year you all
become Top Contributor 2019 I'd love to
continue the interviews if you get a
chance to make it out to either Dublin
or Hong Kong we'd love to hang out we're
gonna hopefully do a fun run in both of
those places the Hong Kong one will be
very interesting yeah yeah eat a whole
bunch of breakfast [ __ ] run 10k now
it's been such an honor and a privilege
to share the room with all these amazing
people I've learned so much about you
here I didn't get a chance to talk to
Jesse I didn't get a chance to talk to
so many people that I want to but stick
around I think we're gonna we're gonna
clean up real quick we've got lots of
food if you want to take some home with
you I'm gonna take a lot of food and
stuff into my pockets and maybe do this
the santa salmon thing from that movie
pretty video vers that movie dan Aykroyd
dressed up as a saint up putting a
salmon and Trading Places thank you such
a good movie do you want to go back and
watch like politically-incorrect 1980s
movie that's a great place to start
so I am so thrilled that everybody came
and freako camp is early days we are
rapidly growing in terms of people in
the community the amount of things out
there that we're creating for other
people to learn from the amount of
Rockstar
developers and teachers that are that
are coming through freako camp so we
want to absolutely continue to
facilitate as many people as possible
who want to learn to code because my
firm belief is that just like you had to
learn to read
when point type slides and things like
that in the 90s if you wanted to
continue to work as a knowledge worker
now you need to learn to code and
regardless of how your job may seem like
oh I don't necessarily see where coding
would be directly applicable to this I
think it will be sooner or later because
what we're seeing is jobs are the
expectations are just getting higher and
higher for your understanding of
technology to be able to take these
mainframes that we carry around in our
pockets and put them to work for us
because most of the work in society
today is done not by humans but by
robots and there's a very small category
of people who are telling those robots
what to do but we want everybody to be
able to tell those robots what to do we
want to have everybody empowered with
the rapidly exploding computational
power that is falling in price every
year that we can all put to work so that
everybody is you know a Tony Stark like
superhuman who can just command the
world around them and we'll get there
very soon and so I'm optimistic that by
helping more people become comfortable
with technology and learn how to code
and learn how to work with databases and
use all these tools at our disposal
we'll be able to you know expedite the
the arrival of the singularity like
scarcity society where everybody's just
super enriched and everybody is able to
live lives of leisure and lives of mind
so what we're gonna absolutely get there
and everybody in this room is helping us
get there faster so thank you and for
everybody who's watching this again I
hope some of these amazing people have
inspired you to get involved in the
developer community and to contribute to
open source and to turn around and teach
all the things that you're learning and
to to be utterly voracious and
relentless in your personal development
so we're gonna pack everything up we're
gonna go if anybody wants to go grab a
drink or grab a dessert I'm not sure
where we're gonna go but I do think we
need to leave this place or too late
thank you again everybody for for being
here
[Applause]
you